all right
and we are live the last word lord
cognito ibontas and ty guy astutious
travis
fresh on that uh thursday campfire i'm
feeling the vibes man feeling the vibes
very very sturdy so i'm digging it so i
had to compliment it you know what i'm
saying but let's start with ebay
oh yeah we see that we got a match there
we go
refined gentlemen that's what i'm
talking about let's go how are we going
to eat those look at crispy what are
those some new little things these are
i've had them for a little while they're
uh gamer advantage they're blue lights
glasses yes yeah
i got them because they have like really
if i could have like just like the
thinnest frame so they could be under my
headphones yes that's the whole point so
they were like really thin frames
flexible so i got those um
no me let's see um since i talked to you
guys last on thursday
uh marathon horizon zero done and the
frozen wilds dlc had a 13-hour stream on
monday
five hours left for the frozen wilds dlc
to finish that one up so we got
everything done um
that has climbed very high on my ps4
generation chart of games
um
like god of war is probably still my
number one
bloodborne's still like my first souls
game so that's kind of got a special
spot but like
again like i haven't played it in a
while and until it gets to 60 frames
patch i'm not touching it again like
that's one of those things like i'm not
going back until it looks right and i
think horizon
because i played about eight hours or so
previously
like when it came out and then zelda
came out and then another season of
modesty came out so i fell off of it so
i went through and it was like the
eastern continent i was like about seven
eight hours i was like i got through all
that and then i went to where everything
got bigger and opened up
man that game just like
so much
was fun about it like i really
thoroughly enjoyed the story like the
voice acting and like then lance riddick
yeah he's in there somewhere you'll get
to him at a certain point his depth gets
kind of interesting but like i enjoy
combat that's one of those things that
like the more you play the more i've
gotten into
like souls games and stuff good combat
will
like probably put a game even higher
than it should be maybe for me but
honestly like the game has so much to
have like the music too i was playing
the frozen wilds dlc that soundtrack
when you're in the middle of a battle
dude i'm like i have to go look up this
song because like the drum beat and
everything going on when you're fighting
some of these frozen grizzly bears is
just like amazing um but the combat in
that game the progression the way you
really start to get your tools and you
have different ones that i even would
have expected it was
it was a ton of fun chat was cool like
started at nine in the morning like two
o'clock like i got a big raid from a
future guest actually we're gonna have
on
and then
just like 100 people were watching and
just like kept going so that was fun um
and then i installed a new garbage
disposal and today i installed a toilet
upstairs so
not only did i like marathon a game did
some diy projects at home and then to
date like last night and this morning
i'm about two hours in and nobody saves
the world
which is nice fun little game like
i'm kind of enjoying the progression of
i just got to the point where you can
start customizing abilities and
characters and i'm like okay i see where
this is going um
because you can have you start with this
little rat and you're like
what are you doing and then all of a
sudden you have like a knight
and then he can slash and now the rat
can poison but the arrows can poison but
you can stop i'm like all right now i
see the intrigue here so
that one is definitely gonna be a buddy
of mine like beat it in about 16 hours
he played pretty hard through it so
between him and the stuff i've seen i
saw skill up do a higher recommendation
i saw you guys listen to your whole
interview with the dev oh man
oh yeah whole thing um maddie was more
interested i honestly sit i sent that to
my friend and i had to put a caveat on i
was like by the way i think this might
be more about the business of making it
not so much about like the mechanics in
the game because that was pure business
interview i love maddie because during
the thing like the first three four
questions is all business and people
forget maddie is making a game myself
right so he's all into this so in part
about myself like yeah oh grab about
this game you got that's cool that could
change forums and it's cool like i was
like let's get back to the game
by the time i got done i was like i
don't know how much i actually know
about the game there's zero spoilers
tweet t's and mechanics i probably got
more from skillups review than i did
from you guys it was cool to hear it
was like talked about like the sony
background and all of that type of stuff
but overall very very fun um couple
hours so far and i can see where the
progression is going to go so yeah
fairly cool all right hold on
i'll be right back no doubt no doubt
just real quick before i give it a try
um and maddie's defense i got to give
him that um
you know he did get some really good
gems on the indie scene of like how
to pitch their game how game pass works
like we he got a lot of gems from him on
the business side but enough about all
that trev what's been going on man it's
uh has the light been dying for you yes
indeed it has yeah i haven't had a ton
of time for some of the indies other
people have been playing just because i
got straight off of the windjammers 2
review into
dying light too lots of sequels now they
think about it um
but yeah uh i
have spent almost the entire week
playing dying light 2. i've now played
over 100 hours of that game
took me about
80 hours to complete the game which is
a lot shorter than i thought it might
take based on the um
the advertised times uh granted i
basically did
i did a ton of the side quests early in
the game and then the second half of the
game i was like okay i think i get it in
terms of side quests let me just let me
just finish the story now and see how
that turns out so uh i finished the that
but i actually did finish a surprising
amount of the game like i got 100 of the
facilities opened up and i claimed all
the windmills and all that stuff so um
yeah i did i did a pretty like thorough
playthrough considering that i you know
only had the game about a week and a
half early so
um i'm going to be writing my review
tonight and then my review will go live
february 2nd i think that would be
seven in the morning so absolutely um
yeah i've just been playing a ton of
that game uh and preparing to do
uh crossfire x as my next review and i'm
waiting on that
yeah that one's going to be interesting
and then i'm pre i'm previewing the new
uh assassin's creed valhalla dlc
next week so i got to work on that but
yeah dude it's been a really busy uh
month the good news is
um with dying light 2 out of the way
pokemon coming out just in time for me
to be done with
dying light i
i'm on track to meet my absurd goal of
of beating every february game
before
before it gets piled on because i get an
advantage though because i get to i get
to get some of these games out of the
way early and you get like a head start
i would the one i would pay like after
doing horizon i would i would pay sony
like three times the cost of the game
just to play horizon early so it's fresh
and it's done like man what i would give
to get a review copy of that one it was
so in the in the past i have reviewed i
reviewed the first forza or not forza
the first horizon zero dawn game
sorry forza horizon never mind yeah yeah
i was like i get what happened yeah but
i reviewed the first horizon zero dawn
game and when i reviewed it they gave me
the game like a month early and so i got
it i got done with that game like way
before zelda came out and then i
remember my review of that game came out
like the same day breath of the wild
came out and no one read my review
because everybody was just focused on
breath of the wild and how amazing that
game was so i got that game got
completely just like left in the in the
dust by uh breath of the wild but um
where do you rank those two personally
like do you find breath of the wild
better than horizon or where do you
because those two are always compared
yeah do you even compare that on the
same day i don't really compare them i
think my review of horizon zero donna
gave a nine out of ten
and i would say horizon does like pretty
much everything right in terms of
gameplay and in terms of
uh its graphics and the stuff that you
do like fighting giant dinosaurs is just
awesome and i was super addicted to that
game i i don't think the story is very
good uh in horizon zero dawn like can we
differ on that but that's fine yeah we
kind of talked about that a little bit
already but like my big issue with it is
that it's just like it's so
disconnected from the main character
like the main character basically has
nothing really to do with the story
you're sort of just like finding out
about these things that happened
thousands of years ago but i don't
like when you get to the end of them
like a museum i don't know when you get
to the end of it the main character to
me has so there's a lot of importance to
the main character in that story when
you get to the end it takes some time to
get there but when you get some of the
reveals it hits
it hit pretty hard when i was watching
personally but again that's like this is
why there can be critical pieces over it
but yeah if you actually had a chance to
play one enjoy it kind of in capsule and
then you're like cool here's the review
never mind everybody's going to talk
about zelda yep what are you doing
you've beaten zelda have you played in
beat zelda yeah i i i was so happy that
i got to review horizon xeridon
specifically because it meant that i
could focus on zelda when it came out
i will admit my color of breath of the
wild is a little bit
um tainted by the fact that i had just
got done playing horizon zero dawn for a
month and i was super over open world
games yeah by the time i came out i was
just like i was like dude i do not want
to play
and i think something i think something
came out in the fall that's that year
before as well that i was playing that
was super open world i was playing it
for a really long time and then res and
dirt on and by the time i was done with
horizon zero done i was so over open
world games and i played breath of the
wild but i will say breath of wild is a
great game like i i know like a lot of
people have uh
have
you know their problems with uh
breath of the wild and other people
think that it's you know the the
greatest game that's ever uh made and
i'm sort of in the middle i think it's a
great i think it's a great game i really
wish it had dungeons i i that's what
yeah that's right
i don't really mind the weapons breaking
thing i i'm like whatever too easy to
find who cares you know
um actually dying light has the same uh
mechanic where you're constantly
grabbing weapons and they break but it
doesn't really matter because weapons
are so easy to come by that that you're
never like oh man i wish i had well why
does my weapon have to break it's not
really that big of a deal so
yeah i see lots of people disagreeing
with the with with my take on the story
that's totally within your rights but i
will say i'm not i haven't given you
guys like my full reasoning i have a lot
of problems with the story in that game
whether it's like zavala's characters
weird betrayal and that whole like magic
[ __ ] that he does
uh i i i yeah i have a lot of problems
with the story in that game but uh i
think the character aloy is great and i
i'm super excited for the sequel and i
think if they can focus
on the story more the gameplay sort of
takes care of itself like the gameplay
in that game is so so so good like i
love that game i gave it a nine out of
ten yeah i was like
even if you have that
only problem really is the i think the
narrative is just a little just
disjointed but i mean that's kind of one
of those things when you made the
reference of
what is
your perspective going into any game and
it can definitely be affected by your
previous experience whether you just
spent 50 hours in an open world whether
for me versus say cogs co-host if you
guys don't watch the finding dude please
do uh maddie like maddie is hard hard
not a fan of death loop
my first arcane game and i did actually
thoroughly enjoy just like the
ridiculous nature like the voice acting
but again people are like go play pray
go play the dlc to play go play
dishonored like
there are
very good examples of extremely good
archaic arcane games so if that's your
expectation you're like if i can get
here and then if i could see just a few
more things but for me i was like it was
all brand new
so that's why for me the perspective
makes perfect sense and i think that's
why it's probably also one thing i will
definitely say
if you get a chance to play it now do it
on a ps5 if you're going to go back yeah
or pc because the ssd load times as soon
as i got the unlimited fast travel i was
bouncing around everywhere and it only
took a few seconds to load i'm like i'm
thinking old school
ps4 spinning hard drive this might have
sucked a little more so overall i
definitely did man the load times were
real in ps4 era that's when i reviewed
it and i i think they needed to give me
the game a month in advance just for a
load time
i mean that's the thing about bloodborne
that's why i want to remaster a
bloodborne so if you die you're just
like right back in right there yeah also
i just want to say i've played every
arcane game right when it came out and
oh listen
matty's views on death loop are just
insane so like don't even like
it's crazy man it's crazy like i i get
what he's saying but like he said that
that game's the worst game that came out
in 2021 which is an absurd view that's
it's really only true if you've played
like five games in 2021 like if you
didn't play the best
but not everybody had to go through nerf
legends we know i know but even if you
didn't play nerf legends i personally
reviewed like i don't know 12 games that
were way worse than death loop like come
on man that's it's not even a real
argument that's him having arcane
expectations so hopeful in his head and
apparently it just did not get there for
him that's why he's like make a game
worse though your expectations doesn't
make sense that's all i can come up with
though cause i had so much fun like ask
my stream i was just like
i would go through a level in death loop
and whether you played i don't want to
spoil it cog but it's like you know
there's multiple levels and times i
would just go through and have fun
clearing the entire thing out just
because it was goofy fun whether it was
my little silence pistol or whatever i
just had fun doing it and i think
and then when you started to put them i
was when i finally realized i was like
this is a big
first person shooter escape room
it was actually really cool i think
that's one of those when i finally
because i've done real life escape rooms
so when i got a chance to play one in a
video game over time traveling escape
room first person i was like yes sign me
up this is a blast so
that's me of course he's done real life
escape rooms
that's like the
i've never done an escape room and the
reason i've never done an escape room is
because the people who tend to do escape
rooms have turned me off from them
show me one person
who has ever done an escape room and
hasn't told everyone about it everyone
in their life that they've done in
escape room that's why i'm i'm annoyed
by escape rooms but now i've never done
one real quick challenge to ask you this
because i know the death loop
controversy
you're trying to kill my boy daddy first
ridiculous super well-reviewed game
i was like it was game of the year
nominated so it can't be
anything let me let me ask you this
you ha
halo yeah hardcore you know
the mechanics the essence you know when
it's at its peak
so like
that's like somewhat in his in his eyes
like someone what would we say is like
what the one what would it say reaches
multiplayer yeah was like
controversial or was even forward was
even worse it was even worse right so
that's like someone said playing four
for the first time like yo
this is the difference halo
the difference cog is that it would be
like if if 343 or bungie made a
different game that wasn't halo and then
we ju we judged it by the same
it's not a sequel it's a new ip of
course of course a different thing it's
deadly but what if they took the
mechanics that you love
that made that that they're known for
the things that they know for
i mean they kind of did that with
destiny yeah
it was like we're gonna make a different
game now and it's gonna be totally
different we're gonna call it destiny
it's not going to be halo and i play
that game all the time but you have to
realize it's just a different thing
that's like it'd be like if you really
liked halo wars and then when halo 5
came out you were like this isn't an rtx
he'd rather have dino crisis back i'm
like sorry but i'm going to pass on that
one by the way
zero dot like i don't need dino crisis
arcade shooter of dinosaurs i'd much
much rather take what we got in horizon
yeah horizon was an amazing game and
actually i have not touched it since my
review which was years ago yeah and i
i'm completely blind when it comes to
the sequel for ben west i've only seen
the e3 reveal when they announced that
the game was coming that's right i've
seen that reveal and they keep doing
teases i'm trying to do the same thing
i'm not seeing any of them i've not seen
anything i've tried
the big like vgas or e3s or whatever it
was shown substantially is most of what
i've seen because i'm with you now i'm i
don't want i don't need to know anymore
i don't need to know the progression i
already saw one new dinosaur i'm like i
wish i wouldn't have even seen that but
what do you even have to cog i know one
thing you did this weekend
so
microsoft activision gave you a lot of
content
for the facts yeah
oh my god it was insane man but uh shout
out to adam he was in here earlier and
in the chat and um yeah we just went for
it man we just like we knew it was a
moment one of them
seismic moments in the industry
everybody's got an opinion everybody's
got a hot take and it was just like you
know what
let's just get
everybody involved
and people were like hey
like live on the fly i want to get a
part but i'm like all right i'll get you
in here get you in here but you got to
be quick gotta get you out and that was
kind of like the rules you can't stay
you come in you know you come in for an
outfit but it was it was really cool
just to see
everybody come through and then so many
people even if they disagreed with each
other what i like is we kept that
respect you know from different opinions
and stuff like that and shout out to
everybody man colin came through
um man so many hog was on fire he had
his boy king gave the sermon of all
sermons i'm telling you right now just
the price permission for king right now
this is like the promise fulfilled so
he's all in his shaman
prophecy bag and he's in it but um yeah
man it was it was it was a six hour
it'd say
opinions i can't passion
jokes
i can't believe it either like to be
honest but it was one of them joining me
when you look back you get emotional
because it was like
we got everyone to come together on
something yeah the community you know
what i mean and that
was total number of like besides do you
have total number of guests who came
what was the total
guests pass through like what was those
things or viewers
no viewers i saw the viewer numbers
they're massive that was crazy it's
crazy it was crazy and we were all
guests too they all had to log on to
we had over at least 18
18 people come through in and out it was
special man it was special and shout out
to everybody they made it they made it
dope but yeah doing that that we had um
sacred symbols and um
defining duke the first ever
because both of our podcasts were on
opposing sides of that whole yeah i
still need to listen to that patreon one
yeah so that was crazy and then yeah man
it's just been an insane week then we
just did dogs listen i'm just happy
that finally
you know things are settling is a little
bit of the aftermath
and um yeah man this week as far as the
games nobody saves the world as far as
destiny i just i finally started playing
and doing my pinnacle activities again
just getting into my week my weekly all
right let me let me just start
accumulating mats shout out to you e i
um
did you did your video with the um
the uh spider
which is basically getting spirals
that day he had the spirals i was like
yes cuz those are not gonna be in which
clean that planet is gone so i got that
out and um yeah man it was i just been
just slowly getting it because i don't
want to be
material deficient and i feel right now
i'm too low
so at least i want to get back in that
routine and get my pinnacles and getting
stuff like that so yeah i'm ready man we
got stuff to talk about shout out to tj7
oh [ __ ]
no no no where can i watch oh it's our
iron lords podcast yeah iron lord's
podcast i did too i don't watch it now
but you know yeah
if you if you got like a work day if
you're gonna walk your dog for like a
marathon
whatever you need
it will occupy
much much time i did wanna say one other
thing like you guys were
going through that podcast that was also
during one of the craziest sports ball
weekends i have ever seen shout out to
the niners who are still alive by the
way in one of the sloppiest
looking i was losing faith some are my
wife like my wife gave me crap
that i was like she said um
oh no they're not gonna win oh that's
the dagger she gave me such a hard time
because i thought it was over so many
times me too just because it seemed like
they didn't have a shot to do anything
so then when something kind of good
happened and then nothing came about it
was like that was our chance
yep it was over yep yep but they looked
dead in the water like they looked so
lethargic and then we're in the dmv and
traps like you know we don't start
playing to the third quarter
and i'm like yeah
was i right though
and i was like
yeah was it like a block point yeah
touchdown and i'm like
it was special teams and defense are the
only reason we are still going because
the offense may as well have barely been
there for about one drive jimmy jimmy g
yeah he needs to hopefully be a little
less sort of this weekend but also every
other game every other game was within a
field goal or end of game field goal end
of game field goal i think they were all
end of game field goals and then over
time which that game i do want to say my
random sports tangent here
is just a little bit of proof why the
coin flip of nfl sucks
personally just because it's a very that
was a very offensive game neither
defense was there ended as it ended up
being what 36 to 42 or something so
obviously the defenses weren't strong
like the other game so then when you
have a coin flip which offense gets it
first they're not really stopping them
and nobody got a chance so that's just
one of those i don't know if it's going
to change but i think for playoffs maybe
playoffs
but i would like to see maybe for
playoffs each team gets some kind of
chance because it did suck to
see the bill's quarterback do what he
did
and then
the rug pulled out from under him that
really sucked
yeah but yeah that was a fun weekend i
don't know if i'll ever watch four games
that were that fun that was crazy that
was crazy
all right all of our fun past week out
of the way
you said you've been playing a little
destiny
or a few weeks out we did actually get a
twabbage
and by the way the zavala picture you
guys see related to the twab one of the
bungie guys
said hey some this this like this looks
like something from a cinematic
so fyi so ball is going to be in some
cinematics somewhere in the future
but it does it does have a different
face like a little more
yeah different tone on him but again if
he's in a cinematic maybe he doesn't die
in the campaign we'll see
we'll see
no way
he's like a mainstay
i don't want him to go just because i
like his voice
genetics bless that man with some
very wonderful pipes
so i hope his voice doesn't leave the
game same thing like in horizon when
he's in there you're like yes more of
him please for sure for sure uh
lieutenant daniels from the wire
[Laughter]
i need to watch yes you do that's a
glass that's that's one of the big
classics for tv that breaking bad both i
know believe me i know wow dude i know
wow wow this guy
guys i don't even know you
[Laughter]
i missed some big ones okay i missed
some big ones
wow okay okay we learned it we learned
well i know
i'll just wait for chat to blow me up on
that one anyway
i can't get on your case than that
there's like a million good shows i got
gaps dude
and everybody's mad if you haven't seen
that you're gonna get better dude
that is one of the things about cutting
the cord
um that i heard somebody mentioned
somewhere recently well we may pl like
almost pay as much as we used to and
probably do with all the different
services depending on what you have each
service has a lot more specialized like
high quality content so you have like
each and every other shows and yeah no
commercials you have netflix you have
hulu you have amazon prime and even if
you get a good show out of all of those
now you have multiple shows to keep up
with it's a really fun time to watch tv
but it is really hard to keep up with
everything like i got to the first
season of ted lasso a year later and i'm
glad i did because that show is
absolutely amazing but it took me a
while to get there so there are certain
ones eventually i'll get there i still
have to watch boba fett which apparently
is a big deal baba boba
um
anyway destiny stuff yes yes yes so
ritual vanguard and crucible oh my we've
got
reputation changes basically going on
with kind of everything that we get a
chance to generally work with whether it
be crucible it's your standard rituals
that are on your director
so for season 15 uh guardians were
approaching the new vanguard ranks
differently um they basically state the
speed of which you get through your
vanguard reputation ranks
they thought it was too slow
and i agree because it does take a lot
like crucible i would say i get through
pretty comfortably
and it's probably because
i avoid the strike playlist
generally because there isn't much of a
reason to go in there once you're kind
of done with your pinnacle so i don't
play it as much as they do have reasons
to play your iron banners or other
things
they are going to try and make that one
faster they're also going to work on
improving
uh just completion rank
activity streak
nightfall multipliers and then nightfall
completion quality so if you get like
platinum rewards potentially you would
get more so just in general they said it
should be about twice as fast for most
players to get through the vanguard
reputation i'm sorry i'm trying to read
this youtube channel
i feel like he is
[Laughter]
this is one perk of having these
hooligans on my monitor in front when i
turn to read the twab it's in a
different place so my periphery there's
these bouncing chuckling heads over here
and i'm like my god
amy sorry professor continued to sum up
vanguard reputation gain should be
approximately twice as fast for most
most players with the ability to
optimize even faster by playing on
higher difficulty nightfalls and
utilizing the activity streak so in
theory it's not going to suck as much to
be in nightfalls or vanguard strikes
and if you do put some time in there if
you want to grind some grand masters
you're gonna actually be benefited by
doing the higher level stuff which
i can't really hold anything wrong sieve
attack by the way cog and travis behave
yourselves shout out to the five dollar
super chat from siva tech getting called
out by chats
happy too
that was funny that's a classic
similarly trials of osiris was about 30
percent slower than anticipated i love
how they have these data metrics
somewhere be to say how many game
sessions did it take for this person to
get through bungie and all their data
how's it feel feels like it sucks is it
yeah it sucks okay
um
one cool thing about trials that they're
gonna do is they feel like they're not
valuing round wins enough especially
when players get to 20 round wins
and at seven win tickets so they've
decided to add a small amount of trials
reputation at match end for every round
that you win so whether it be one that
you win with your super bonus so even if
you go five and one you get a little bit
more for just participating in these
matches which
is kind of what it's come into like
it's more and more participation
trophies it seems with regards to trials
so trial so travis's hope for the
refined nature of a glory playlist is
what it seems like it needs more and
more because yes there is some
competition when you get to like a 7-1
card or if you want to go flawless but
there's a lot of blue ribbons being
handed out in trials it does seem
because i have got a lot of engrams
i went flawless because that one dude
helped me but there's been a lot of
participation in grams on my part during
the course of this by the way i don't i
don't i don't mind the blue ribbons i
actually think that trials and
competitive modes should be way more
rewarding than they are even if you're
losing i just want there to be
some way to kind of get ranked with like
skilled players you want to grind out
for like onyx
in in destiny exactly i want to be able
to do
the same thing in destiny because you
know it's fun to do it in halo but i
don't get to take all of my years of
achievement and inventory and armor and
weapons with me in halo so there's a
there's a special quality to destiny and
i think this is great i'm glad they're
doing this i think all these changes are
good i also would like it if my team had
any incentive to win matches you ever
play a a game of like crucible or
gambit or whatever and realize that
nobody there actually cares about
winning i like and it's so good they
will capture a point and then go like
yeah b-line to try and get a few kills
with very certain weapon types
i mean i did the same thing that's the
problem with the whole
bounty system that we are in right now
is
whether it be strikes gambit or crucible
so many
um
so many things in this game tell you to
go do an activity a very specific way
yep so if i need sidearm kills for this
one bounty i'm just gonna be getting
shot in the face half the time but i
don't care because eventually with
enough deaths i'm bound to probably get
some sidearm kills which doesn't really
help a whole bunch uh i did see that
yeah yeah there's i mean
what do the bounties do at this point
mostly they just give us experience
towards our season pass and our crucible
rank
yeah
and it's just one other thing for people
to do um
iron like the iron banner uh bounties
you need to do if you want to get
powerful drops and then there's some
like uh quests that aren't really
bounties but they still make you act
weird like crucible is toxic as heck the
first month when everybody's grinding
out that seasonal exotic weapon because
you always have to do that in crucible
oh i gotta do something because yeah
yeah and especially if the weapon's not
good i think it was a sidearm one year
and it was just like everybody was out
there with the worst sidearm in the game
like lawrence driver this season like
linear fusions
drivers are
it's still very spammy like when
everybody's using that you're like oh my
god yeah so
um i i think they
they they should find a way to make it
so that it's not
your only incentive like may maybe your
earlier your kills only matter if you
win the match you know something like
that so there's some sort of incentive
to win
uh but yeah i don't think they'll do
that i hear badly i'm sorry i get it no
i was just new rad said in chat like
remove the artifact and i don't know if
they'll go that far
but in theory at least remove the levels
yeah the levels don't do us any good
they already say grandmaster is your cap
that's the highest thing contest
modifier when the raid matters doesn't
matter there
master and lost sectors after a while i
mean yeah we had a long season this time
but generally
once you get to a certain point
it's just slowly making things but they
tend to you never feel that powerful
that is one thing i will say in playing
through horizon zero dawn i did like
almost every side quest i did a lot of
them i went through and checked up so by
the time i got to
the final mission i was about level 50.
well it tells you to be like level 35.
so i was a little overleveled i was
running through fighting stuff really
amped up and actually felt
a little extra powerful
like you would in a general rpg with
progression we still i've it just
reminded me of how we don't get that in
this game
yeah i i i do miss i think it was d1
what was the name
of the event where they brought the
raids
they they kind of make you they brought
the power level up of the old raids like
king fall
and um age of triumph or whatever it
sounds like triumph yeah i miss that
because i remember going in there and
just wreck it and i'm like yeah like i
don't know it just felt good sometimes
it does feel good when you're off level
or way above level to melt something or
what i like what i miss about it is we
would really sherpa during that season
that time because it was like okay
somebody's new they haven't played for a
while you want to do this you want to
check this out and they just felt like a
part of it so it's just like i agree
with you he's like i always feel like
if the artifact is gonna matter like let
us dps crush for the people who truly
are invested into that leveling because
of the artifact power on top of it i
still feel like
things should be hurting just as much as
they did
you know when you you you were at the
level with you know that the activity
kind of started i i hate that like when
you look at recommended power level this
is what bothers me we look at
recommended power level for any activity
and you are leaps and bounds above it
yeah you should melt
really hard like your dps should and i
still feel there's that curve where it's
like they're only letting you
go up to this certain level it's really
oh you're delta above is like a max of
20. so a vanguard strike you can't just
go in there and just destroy strikes and
honestly those should just be fun
strikes should not be anything that you
need to sit there and put a decent and
you can obviously nuke some stuff in
there but still
just have some fun
yeah
absolutely it's just to me it's all
about damage resistance and
sustainability that's all it is so i
don't i don't get hurt enough when i'm
not one shot that's why i'm leveling up
really i'm not leveled up so i'm feeling
more powerful than the enemy and that's
what i want to do it's homework yeah
yeah it's homework
it's giving me the right to play it
sorry okay yeah no that's actually what
it is it does it gives you it checks a
box so you qualify to
basically play the activity but it never
matters that much once you if you if
you're doing something really difficult
they're going to tell you exactly how
you're going to play it if you're doing
something mid-level
it's you're just going to play it kind
of as it should feel and but you never
get to feel overly strong ever agree
uh continued reputation changes so we
got the
vanguard changes we got the trials
changes also it looks like we've got the
summoner coming back
so we've got our
auto rifle i think it's a 600 rpm
see if we get maybe
yep solar i'm trying to think there's
nothing actually
no i was actually going to say yeah
solar auto rifles there's not a ton that
i love because there's that one from
beyond light which i can't really stand
the way the recoil is because it's just
all over the place it's
thermal erosion or something maybe oh
yeah it happens it does not feel good
this at least if you could get maybe
vorpal and something like that for
champions especially as their overload
um
auto rifles and smgs that will actually
be good they said for reputation changes
with regards to crucible they say that
feels about right they're not going to
mess with iron iron banners are getting
a rework in season 17 so fy
spent we're probably going to spend our
tokens this season
um they say gambit reputation was about
30 slower than desired
but with the gambit revamp coming in
witch queen which we still don't know
because that's in a future twab uh they
would like a full season to analyze play
styles and patterns before making any
changes more details on that in the
future and this is one i wanted to ask
you guys
they think it's 30 too slow whatever
their data says
solar haze arcticus that's the that's
the auto rifle sorry right
the lmg thank you
thank you but if they know something is
30 slow and it's gambit
nobody likes to play in the first place
anyway it's barely and it's like land
and they're doing some rework that's
fine
but if it already goes that much slower
i don't know how much the rework is
going to do unless there's if it's still
going to be called gambit it's still
probably going to be generally the same
do you guys think not touching that 30
reputation gain
is
kind of the wrong decision or do you
guys think that's okay and wait and see
how everything comes out
it's a weird
weird thing to address because they're
addressing all the other ones and it
seems like it wouldn't be that
dissimilar to just adjust how much
reputation you get from each gambit
match so that it's about the same um
that said it doesn't really affect me
too much i don't anticipate playing a
whole lot of gambit in between now and
whenever they fix it i have avoided that
game mode like the plague and i
intend to continue to do so for as long
as uh feasibly possible so
um
yeah i i don't really it doesn't really
affect me but it is weird it's weird
that they would say hey we know that
this is broken we're not gonna fix even
though we are fixing these other
playlists that
you know are presumably have the exact
same need so
um it does take forever to level up it's
just strange
yeah it's just strange i'm with you i
mean i
clearly they have a plan for gambit some
at some point but it's just weird that
maybe they just want to coincide
everything together
at one time i i i don't know i mean
that's the thing they are actually
making changes in witch queen but
they're not touching the reputation
they're waiting probably a full season
even later like when they would change
iron banner then they would change that
to me basically just one of those gambit
cannot get a whole lot of play i don't
know what the numbers are but i do not
anticipate that those are that is a very
populated playlist
so why not bump up the 30 and just give
it to us just to give people some
incentive to say hey if you go into the
gambit playlist
it's a it's a bit more generous than it
was to work through your reputation it's
not as long or you get more engrams from
it you might get more rewards
it seems like little change like you
could be extra generous in that one
crucible goes decently vanguards get an
update if nobody wants to play game in
the first place why not give it the bump
i feel like it needs the bump anyway it
could even use double the bump it could
be
if it's 30 too slow maybe it's 30 faster
than the other two just so you go in
there
it's one of those that i feel
that was just a weird one not even say
we think it's 30 slower we kind of want
to see how it goes but we're going to
give 15 of a bump just to not maybe
overdo it but nothing just felt weird to
me when i read this i haven't said that
in my little videos
it just seemed like they could have done
anything to help boost the incentive to
play gambit and they didn't do anything
they're gonna rework it but instead of i
guess we'll see what that is if if i had
to guess let me put corporate cog hat on
if i had to guess you need to get your
hat yeah we got to get me a corporate
car cat um the reason would probably be
the algorithm probably says
play time
is probably the shortest and you know
bungie don't like
you dipping and dodging and getting hot
rewards and stuff real quick we don't
like that we need to keep you here what
do you get from gambit a bottom dollar
with 7 000 perks
you know have you looked at the perk
trees for bottom dollar or some of those
weapons oh yeah it's correct it's just
how many do you have i have about 12 in
each column good luck with the
statistical odds of getting the role you
want
i will say though servant leader though
server late is kind of fire i'm holding
on to i got a crazy role for um when
scouts come back for which queen yeah i
i like that but yeah i mean i'm with you
man i can't really argue with you and
it's like this is it's just it's just
i'm just being ridiculous
there's a problem it's clearly a problem
i just try to understand their mindset
that's all right i get that and maybe
the changes are going to be different i
don't know what they're going to do but
if it is still going into a gambit match
whether you change
you know if it's longer if it's a little
bit more competitive a little more back
and forth it's still going into gambit
and whatever the experience is is good
bad or otherwise
knowing the reputation slower i feel
like still isn't going to
be something that the revamp is going to
change
unless drifter's menu looks completely
different which maybe who knows maybe
uh they said they're also not making any
changes to the active streak system or
the placement of the ritual weapon
ornaments i did want to ask you guys
this one because the ritual ornaments
are part of the seasonal challenges
and one of those
each seasonal ornament is somewhere like
its own seasonal challenge
and basically what that means is right
now for every reputation you go all the
way through crucible up to 16
when you go to reset when you get to 16
then you can pull the new pursuit weapon
next time you go through it your full
second reset you get the ornament
when you go to gambit or vanguard even
though you have earned the weapon your
first reputation reset is going to give
you the weapon again
then your second one is going to give
you the ornaments same thing with gambit
so you have to reset every single one of
them three times even though you've
already you're gonna get the weapon
three times
so it is a little annoying to
to me at least my opinion would be if
you could take the order if you go
through one once and then you go through
it twice you've got the ornament for
you've got the one ornament already
then if you could take the ornament from
the second reset pull it to the first
reset for the other two vendors like i
spend a lot of time in crucible
i go through one two resets i get my
ornament well now if i go into vanguard
well i've already got the weapon now if
i go through one reset in the strike
playlist i get the ornament here if i go
through one reset i get through the
ornament here
it just seems it seems excessive when
you're going through all three like i'm
not gonna do the gambit one
just it was the one ornament that was
sitting out there for me and i was like
nope not gonna touch it because i don't
want to go through it if it was one
reset
i could i could maybe get but two not
gonna happen yeah once you have the
weapon it's like well i gotta get the
weapon again and then like for each each
ritual activity yeah it's a bit much
travis any opinions or am i just all
right yeah i know you guys are preaching
i mean you know you know me i will
always side with the person that's
saying that we should have to play the
same activity less often because i get
so bored just doing strikes over and
over again and
same with gambit you know there was like
a time where gambit was a good mode back
when they were really putting a lot of
their
time and effort into it and you could go
in with a full stack of four and just
blow through it but it's been so
exploited since then and pared down to
the most like basic version that it's
just not good and uh really aside from
crucible there's nothing i'll i really
get a kick out of just like
replaying so the the fact that there's
even a reputation grinding thing for
vanguard for strikes is terrifying to me
like i i can't imagine sitting in that
playlist for that long and redoing the
same missions i've done over and over
again that's just that just does not
strike me as fun at all like i can
imagine doing it for
uh crucible easily because you know it's
multiplayer it's sort of dynamic and
evergreen you know but for strikes
damn dude like i remember doing that in
destiny one back when there was the uh
what was it called the seven of
seven of coins coin
yeah yeah what was it called was the
thing called uh well skeleton keys is
that what you're thinking seven seven of
what was the name of that thing
you know the exotic farmer
yeah it was a thing i know what you're
talking about
a chance to get like an example or
something to get the exotic
seven of something something of course
drop rate or something yeah yeah three
or four three of coins three of coins
yeah
just had the number wrong yeah the coins
yeah
three yeah so i i remember the three of
coins thing i would grind strikes but
all we did in that party chat was talk
about how much we hated strikes and how
much this was new crap that we were
having to grind this way um i still did
it like i did it for hours to try to get
everything but i was not happy i just
think uh
the fact that they're trying to turn
that sort of content into like evergreen
content that you just grind over and
over again just doesn't sit well with me
it doesn't strike me as a very
compelling
uh gamer experience this is one of those
where i have to wonder about the average
casual person who logs on at 10 o'clock
after the kids go to bed they got about
an hour hey let me boot up i can just
play a couple strikes enjoy the shooting
in this game and they get to play a few
hours a week and that's what they get
that may be their thing but believe me
travis i agree with you
trust me like spending time in the
vanguard playlist which is going to be
getting a change which is something
perfect to talk about right now
good job can we can we really quickly
before we move on address uh what
somebody in the chat said which was that
three of coins was a great game mechanic
i really really hope you're being
sarcastic
because uh that is the worst mechanic
they've ever created like and i
can you imagine
needing a consumable to fix the broken
drop rate on your own that's all it did
it was like a it was like a thing you
had to spend in-game currency on just to
make the drop rate in the game not
terrible that's what you had to do and
you had to remember to do it in between
every strike it it is the ammo synth of
rng and it is terrible and you shut your
mouth and don't talk about game
mechanics ever again unless you were
being sarcastic so that's all i have to
say to that commenter anywho
speaking of the vanguard playlist what
dj
poor tj he brought that on himself
sarcasm
as we discussed in earlier 12 the season
13 battlegrounds will be added to the
vanguard strikes playlist which is now
renamed vanguard ops as a reminder the
four new battlegrounds coming to the new
seasons are behemoth on nessus oracle
and nessus hailstone on europa and
foothold on cosmodrome the actual
battleground activities are the direct
launch
no champion version of the battlegrounds
as these match the length and difficulty
of the most of the strikes in the
playlist any bounties quest triumphs and
challenges used to uh reference strikes
now reference vanguard ops i really
actually hope with regards to the
bounties that it's plastered and bright
and clear and in bold
because sometimes whether it's a
challenge or a bounty
typically i think it was the challenges
where i found the issue or maybe a
triumph you need to do for a season
thing do this in strikes and you go into
a nightfall and you see no progress no
progress that's annoying like strikes
should be one thing it's a box
everything on that window should count
if it's the zavala icon that counts
towards those bounties or triumphs or
i'm gonna go to a harder strike it's a
nightfall it's the same thing over and
over it's boring so reward me for it
i will say too though as i was going
through some of the challenges for one
of the recent seals
it's been a year
and i know beyond light is something
they still charge for and we have our
all of our pricing debates the empire
hunts should be in vanguard ops because
if you do those on a relatively low
difficulty they are about the same
length as the strike
and they're not they have
huh they sure you wait are we talking
about the one i mean how long are some
of these strikes
how long is like the shadows no not the
no not which one's empire empire hunts
the beyond the europa the three
technocrats
yeah yeah the technocrat those are
strikes yes yes yes those just should be
dumped into vanguard ops as well so then
you'd have
empire hunts on europa
you only have one strike on there anyway
then you'd have the battlegrounds and
then you'd have strikes i agree you
already have them in the game just make
that playlist more varied
i think that would be i'm sorry and
again that's the point where but you
have to buy beyond light to be able to
access these that's the little caviar
that's it but i mean that's it you have
a vanguard ops playlist you want us to
spend some time in there spice it up
no i agree i agree i heard the word hunt
and immediately thought of that thing
with the traps with crow what's that
what's the name of that cryptalism
yeah i know what you're talking about
the yeah the one for zebra wrath and you
literally like just stand kill a green
monster stand in the pool and shoot the
thing and be over with the things that
you can farm in 30 seconds if you do the
glitch for the team yeah
yes yes all of that stuff that we have
farmed for currencies all that stuff's
going away
yeah yeah tangled tangled's gone uh the
other big born hunt thanks
gotta love chat giving us corrections in
here
yeah
uh
well you can remember all the names
though of all the currents that's the
funny thing is though if you listen to
anything you listen to any podcast we're
all in the middle of it in the moment of
course everybody else knows that all
listen to a podcast and you're screaming
at them through the podcast earphones
you're like this is totally what it's
called do a podcast and tell me if you
remember everything on the fly you won't
it's just not gonna happen but shout out
to all of you watching right now if you
are enjoying the show please drop a like
uh if you're watching on youtube or
whatever channel you're walking on drop
a like leave a comment subscribe to
those channels
also by the way if you guys do listen to
this on audio um please drop us a review
um give us a rating on those platforms
whether it's spotify itunes google play
wherever it is the reviews help move us
up in the charts so more people can find
us and view us and listen to us so if
you are out there listening watching
whatever it may be please drop a little
love it's always appreciated yes yeah i
gave this podcast a five-star review
but i did it one star at a time i just
gave you guys a one one star review
every week we're gonna need to talk
after the show because that um
that's like a subscription model i
thought you guys liked uh games as a
service type stuff
but you don't you like drip drip cause
i always talk about you love drip feed
content i'm just trying to give you your
reviews
we had to have a reprimand after that
we're gonna have a chat with our co-host
over here
you guys were doing fine on itunes until
somebody bombed you we got reviews
[Laughter]
so to make up for travis's misgivings
please
drop us some positives the five stars
definitely help for positive reviews
take care of this man
give all your stars at the same time
however many you decide to give that's
my
anywho nightfall changes the other thing
we spent a fair amount of time in this
game uh we've been slowly entering the
pressures and challenges we apply at
each of the nightfall difficulty ranks
one big outlier was the strike specific
modifiers with damage boost and other
effects that enhanced boss attacks
while some of them were cool and fun
there's a lot of sarcasm in here
who doesn't like getting heated five
miles by sediya in the corrupted strike
no way no one likes that everyone hates
that it's really annoying to be booped
off of there
you can try and move to the best of your
ability sometimes but sometimes us
titans have got glue on our feet and
poop
um uh they were generally inconsistent
and were pushing tactical play
more they were punishing tactical play
more than intended build crafting so we
have removed those from nightfalls
starting at hero so there are no more
boss mechanics
all right
we've added a new style of burn called
acute which will increase player damage
taken from a specific element by 50
percent
and increased player damage done by 25
so a little bit of give and take kind of
like the strikes burn is 50 both ways
this is 50 incoming 25 percent outgoing
most nightfalls already have a 25 damage
received modifier so this will be an
across-the-board increase of 25 in both
directions for that element
so basically if there is a very heavily
used damage coming like a fallen strike
for example
you're going to need that damage
reduction element on that chest piece
otherwise you might get a little
squished especially in the high level
stuff if you've got solar snipers
good luck you're gonna need all the
damage medication you can get
but i do like the fact that we're
getting at least a modifier in
nightfalls to give us some benefit
because if there's a whole bunch of arc
in there and you can at least lean into
that it does help you a little bit so
it's not doubly bad there's just a
little risk verse rewards in there uh
secondly we are moving the seasonal
strike modifiers that we introduced in
season 15 from the vanguard playlist to
the nightfalls these are unique buffs
and boosts that aid you if you lean into
the combat themes of the season for
season 16 they are themed to glaive and
void usage
these rotate weekly and appear on all
hero legend and master nightfalls we
look forward to your feedback on these
as we continue to iterate
so i have one question
we had more modifiers and destiny won
then we
probably are getting we're seeing some
unique ones in what dares of eternity we
get a couple of unique ones
we're finally seeing some of those going
into year five
i guess better late than never
yeah it took a while it took a minute
but
i was surprised by that i also wanted to
say that i feel like they're utilizing
the um the burn resistance mods more to
make us use those more with that and the
other thing i wanted to say is
battlegrounds i like that those are
because we love the density of that
activity and shout out to the cops going
by so i'm gonna be yeah see they calling
him out too
what about you travis what are you on uh
the night falls and
do you spend much time in nightfalls for
you are they not really a thing that you
do a lot with
i haven't lately uh i did grandmasters
uh when they first came out and then i
took a little break and i did a couple
or i did a bunch of one of the seasons
but i'm not it's not like a regular
thing for me um my biggest problem with
nightfalls is that it's content i've
already done but they've made it
artificially difficult just because
right and i i just i've had that problem
ever since my first grandmaster i was
like wow i'm getting just like dunked on
by a scion and
a lot of times the only way to beat
those strikes is to come up with cheeses
you know like
you know or what i would consider cheese
is like a titan just constantly
regenerating his uh shield and holding
it up there and generating orbs and then
swapping out with another titan doing
the same thing you know those old
methods with the ursa furiosa and all
that
um
yeah
ursus and wells is what a lot of people
do they just yeah
and and i i would consider that kind of
like cheesy tactics like you you always
have to hide on like a corner of the map
and like come up with some strategy
where you've got like a wall or a well
or something to me that just doesn't
feel like compelling
true gameplay you talk about people
hey we want to pull through people
through the exodus crash garand master
for example they go stand by in one box
and they just rotate through wells and
warlocks and that's all they do so they
can sit there
and even like the people who solo it do
the same thing like you'll see esoteric
sit behind the box because that with a
warlock whether it's devour or well or
whatever the manages to
there's one little exploit spot people
will find and it does feel like that's
that and that's
that's one of those things that i do
hope they do address with regards to
difficulty ever it just feels because
you play you could go through
horizon you could you go through horizon
crank up the difficulty what does that
do you might do a little less damage
they might do a little more but there is
some skill where you can still be aware
of your surroundings and dodge there are
enough random sniper enemies that tend
to ruin your fun
in most high difficulty stuff yeah yes i
did get a haircut for those who asked um
somebody noticed
it's just like it is the difficulty in
this game is frustrating that's why for
me i don't do a ton of grand masters
i've done
devil's lair once i've it just doesn't
the juice doesn't seem to be worth the
squeeze generally some people get to a
point where they've got one or two
people and they just they know their two
classes they can stay alive they find
their spots they find their
here's this one spot what is the
the new
the cabal tidal strike the proving
grounds oh yeah yeah
a little tunnel underneath the little
fire tunnel where you can kind of touch
in there and go through and touch and
you watch people do this
doesn't it's
you're getting a little like pot shots
here and there and like bobbing back and
forth through a tunnel to get one shot
here one shot here one shot here one and
that's all you're doing after all that's
how we're supposed to be playing the
game yeah isn't that what bungie wanted
yeah it's like is that what they want as
opposed to
putting skill into movement or abilities
or a build that you could lean into that
could actually make you
a little tankier do more damage have an
ability to stun a boss for a second
it just some of the cheeses when you see
them done are frustrating they they
should create unique activities for
grandmaster where it's like a strike
that's not in the normal playlist or
they should take the normal playlist and
do something that isn't just ramp up the
light difficulty it should be like
you know add mechanics like raid-like
mechanics to the boss fight where you
have to do more than just kind of like
you know
damage dps rush them or something like
that so i just think they they need
something that isn't just hey do the
same activity but we made it extra hard
and your reward is that you get some
slightly better
materials and adept weapons i just it's
not it's never been for me just for that
reason yeah i'm not a guy who grinds for
seals if you don't grind for seals you
really don't have a reason to do
grandmasters ever so yeah all the way 1
000 agree with travis like shout out to
dj and then he'd be in there and manage
a couple people to clan and they're
gonna be doing gm's and i'm like
for what
like like especially after a while like
i can understand if if you're
you know you're kind of new you got
people in a clan i need some golf balls
to be like all right let's take two
people let's get this guy through let's
stock him up on some golf balls but like
a double reward sorry yeah like a double
reward you can get stuff but i'm
literally sitting at 50 which i'm capped
artificially uh for prisms i'm sitting
at my 10 golf balls i don't i'm not
going to do anything right now with my
armor i've got enough masterwork sets
that i slowly
i don't have any incentive to go in
there because i can go farm exotics in
lost sectors
for me much easier than trying to get a
group together to do a grand master and
it's just something i can go do blindly
on my own without even thinking about it
on master
difficulty lost sectors and especially
as we were this season but grand masters
the effort it takes the time it takes to
go through not worth it it hasn't been
worth it for me
for so long go ahead totally agree
that's why i do way more as soon as the
new season starts i always do way more
what is it master legend law sectors
because i know the chance for a unique
exotic is there like i'm not jumping in
there killing myself
painting and pot shotting people from
deep just so i can get plus five range
on some regular gun like i'm i'm just
not doing that does not sound exciting
to me i'm not killing myself for that if
you talk about okay double rewards okay
i might jump in there once in a while
but the reality is i still
i don't really like the loop with
grandmaster still for me
it's not something i feel excited to do
and to be honest i just i avoid it like
i do not really do i've kind of fallen
completely out of the
nightfall slash grand master stuff i it
just doesn't interest me at all i would
rather do it like i said a the dungeon
or i'll tell you i i get more excited
i'm like oh what's the exclusive titan
or you know exclusive warlock exotic
okay i'm gonna be in there and i'm gonna
keep trying i'm gonna keep trying and
i'll do that all day of the week before
i'll do that other stuff yep that's just
me no i mean that's
and unfortunately it doesn't sound like
a whole lot's changing the modifier is
going to be slightly different so maybe
you can put out a little bit more damage
which is one thing we do need if you
match the
modifier getting more damage out will be
a good thing but again that's one of
those where i think they keep leaning
heavier and heavier
into these single damage type builds
everything you do needs to be arc
everything you do needs to be void
and yet
match game is on everything
that's like high level difficulty so
unless it's just champions and you don't
have to worry so much about match game
it's one of those things that i i'm very
curious when it comes to builds
as they keep leaning because now if
charged with lights a little harder to
do and we have to go elemental wells
that's about the matching the same class
and then when they talk about making
orbs it's all about the same class so
i'm
if they keep doing this type of stuff
and then you still have match game on
you're like you want me to be all art to
have benefit to be able to play this
strike but then if you're going to go
through a solar and avoidance strike but
i have arc damage coming in can't really
do both
just
it seems counterintuitive and it's one
of those things the forcing the elements
is annoying yeah shout out to the
nightbeard five dollar uh canadian super
chat i think that's canadian dollars as
a gambit player i'm scared last
expansion they said they had
improvements coming and they nuked my
armor prime and as a result my clan
i'm sorry you should be scared you
should be scared but that's their yeah
the the stuff that we've seen on gamma
or rather the stuff we haven't seen is
weird especially since they keep uh
pumping it up as a third pillar of
destiny's content like this is the one
of the three main playlists you're
supposed to be in apparently ritual
activity yeah yeah
but hey you know what can't complain too
much because
us crucible pokemon are the same
problem
and your crucible changes are going to
be slow this year on top of that you get
oh yeah one map old map you get one new
map you get two old maps and then maybe
nothing in 19. i think you get a refresh
of trials in season 17 i believe
maybe because it was
i think that's right not the not the
expansion season but the season after
so i mean and then again we have no idea
the pacing of these game modes that
they've supposedly talked about so
that's going to be a slow cadence for
crucible which has already been
years in the making
and gambit somehow getting a rework as
well at the same time i don't expect it
to be big either
which
i don't know how much they can revamp
not gambit without doing something like
they did before making a new node and
redoing other stuff because if you still
have invasions maybe they're a little
shorter maybe they change those you
still have to collect moats which are
network buggy fall through the floor of
the ground
it's really annoying when you're like ah
uh nope i can't pick those up now damn
those types of things i hope they fix
black wings didn't say rift is supposed
to be coming back
so a couple other moments
what is it we used to have our little
team jackets with the the the invader
does this set bonus armor are you
kidding me that was one of the most
annoying teases from somebody who really
likes set bonuses to have that given to
us in a minor idea and then taken away
remember how gassed we was with that
with that driver
i was so excited i was like oh we got
set bonuses now this could be a thing
this is going to set off a chain
reaction
it's gonna
remove for the game and never talked
about again never broke back again it
implemented in any form of like
damn
because that was during when division
was hot yeah at one point so we're like
okay they're leaning in the setbo this
is y'all okay
get a little no no
we've consolidated gambit gotten rid of
prime and taken away that armor and
deprecated it and we will never see it
again
i mean that's what happened so then you
turn around and be like hey are you
excited about witch queen
a weapon seem cool weapon crafting seems
cool the glaive is cool it's all about
the weapons what's your armor doing same
stuff different year
that's how it feels
and from what i've seen we're waiting on
void 3.0 subclasses can be fun
um
we've got some mods coming in but you
know orbs of light and that little shift
like with some of those it's still going
to be mostly about the weapons and the
armor which bugs me still because it's 5
8 of your gear
and somebody else i remember somebody in
chat saying can we not get class items
as pinnacles support that when you get
one or when you get you just i want to
like lock down sections like i don't
need a class item ever again every class
item i get right now bugs me i'm like no
anywho apparently this is my day to rant
and be annoyed
i love it i love
it um
that covers
most of that we do have two weapons
coming back into the nightfall loot pool
we're going to be getting the duty bound
which is the 600 auto rifle that was
from savithoon's song the strike that i
wish we could give back and same with
the silicon neroma that was from i'm
blanking on the strike that one storm
because i looked it up earlier
somebody will tell me uh
it was the pyramidian right
medium pyramidian's no longer in the
game nope yeah so we're getting both of
those back they were kinetic
would you guys expect to see either of
these as stasis weapons
auto rifle because right now we have
shotgun
hand cannon hand cannon linear fusion
mm-hmm
i'm trying to think how many stasis
weapons i'm not counting salvation's
grip that yeah
um fusion rifles in that slot if they're
going to start putting i would be
curious to see it that would be a first
season rifles have never been in that
slot except for the exotics right yeah
just bastion i think that's the only one
yeah bastion so i would i'd be
interested to see if they would ever do
like yeah you could do a trace rifle
there that'd be good a legendary trace
rifle
so that's one thing if they do start
leaning slowly into the stasis thing we
could get some options there so one or
two of these i don't know if they're
going to be they're both pretty good
weapons though sniper right here was
pretty good seen talk about it and
everybody does seem to like that auto
rifle it's a 600 feels pretty good i
like the look of it too i always did
yeah i just wish you could melee and
stab somebody with it yeah like your
melee animation would change when you're
running around at that thing bam and you
might get a little extra that's the type
of stuff
are you running around with a duty bound
auto rifle that monte carlo should add
plus one meter to your melee range or
just something like that like those
little bit of perks to your character
would be a nice little touch cause look
at the weapon it has a giant sword on
the front of it come on yeah and same
thing with monte carlo both could do the
exact same thing
i'm with you man i'm with you uh they
said they're also gonna be
updating how they communicate the
shields present in a strike so you don't
actually have to think about what
enemies you're gonna face just like lost
sectors now you'll know what the burn is
you'll know what shielded enemies are
going to be in there when you pull it up
on your nightfall director which is nice
you can actually plan ahead as opposed
to let me run this thing
crap i forgot this guy's in here let me
go back to orbit and get my different
gear on
unlock the content come back go back to
orbit the whole thing yep yeah
uh lost sectors as well uh when we
introduced legend and master lost
sectors we were forced to split the
daily and legend mass sector
location since there was no way to
select difficulty in a public bubble
thanks to some fresh technology built
for the upcoming witch queen campaign
this limitation is now removed so now
there will be a single daily lost sector
which has both legend and master
difficulties at the same time selectable
at the entrance both difficulties will
give the same exotic reward
so it you are losing one
type of exotic because you could
literally have boots and chests
available in the same day now it's just
everything's the same and consolidated
in one day benefit for somebody like me
if i'm like hey here's your last sector
guide for the day
counts for everything
so it's kind of i i did like the idea of
if i want to go legend i get you know
boots oh but i need chest oh that's
master right over here i could work on
both now you're kind of stuck on your
one daily rotation you one day yeah
that's true
uh a quick touch on crucible as well
that they did do nothing major
they did change the respawn time
back
they reverted it back they said they had
given longer respawn times
and then after the data they've gathered
and the feedback and everything they
said this was not a good idea and we
were reverting it and they did it a few
days ago
so the longer respawn timers that were
in crucible are no longer there travis
is chuckling so i have to ask him
yeah i mean anything that slows down
gameplay sounds like a bad mechanic like
i i feel like this that's like
pretty obvious i think in my book is
like you know waiting longer to do
things i'd be like we increased load
times
it's the same concept right it's like
more time you're not doing things i
don't i think it was a feedback reaction
to people
remember when roman supers were like
super crazy yes and like so i think that
when people were like yo i just spoiled
and they got killed by the same titan in
the same storm caller you know you know
i say like remember that that's i think
that's what it is but the game now has
evolved so now it's like it feels worse
to be put slower because now they've
nerfed the romance i think that that's
what i'm super saiyan stacy somebody was
like almost as bad as freezing but yeah
it was a half measure
to towards not fixing the real issue you
need to fix how the spawns work
yeah not the other piece so right now i
gotta pull it back
uh one thing they are doing a little bit
of a tweak on which is something i can
take advantage of thanks to my new
monitor is hdr
so they're doing an update to it to
where hdr will work in windowed mode um
they're going to have some more tweaks
to it calibration settings will be a
little bit better if you haven't
experienced hdr it is actually pretty
amazing when you get to really see it
pop um between a new tv i've got
upstairs and a new monitor when you do
get either the true back blacks of an
oled or just the the big brightness
contrast of say hdr when i played
horizon zero dawn when i streamed i
couldn't do i can't stream hdr yeah
because obs is like this is overblown
out it looks bad but played a little bit
by myself the benchmark and that type of
thing
that is pr and even destiny when i
played destiny the first time it turned
hdr 100 frames 4k i'm like wow
it's gorgeous when you get to see it in
fantasy nice that's what i was trying to
tell you no i don't know what that
series x stuff was just buzzwords
i tried to tell you i was like man when
you see that hdr hit is different
g-man one no your monitor uh i'm trying
to think is it pg-32uq
um
the fact that you don't have that it's
hilarious pg-32
pg-32 no believe me when it comes to
stuff like this i'll be like yeah no
that's the 1440. they really stuck it
with the brand name there whoever the
marketing team really is the new 4k one
pg 30 no that's that one
because there's like a uq x which is
like three grand it's not that one
because that holds off the ton too
yeah
no but one of them is like 4k but it's
like 1600 mini led dining zones that's
like a 3000 monitor that's more than my
tv i'm like no
this one was the
kind of recently refreshed 4k 144 yeah
it's the pg32uq okay it is that i was
looking at it wrong
um
it's just asus models they're all a mess
go look up anything asus they all have
some of those weird funk about them
uh on a separate note we do have uh a
new community manager as well yeah
what do you guys want to take this one
real quick
all right what did we get what do we get
we have i think
yeah i feel like i'm supposed to be
doing this as the integrity person
we need to talk about bruno community
team continues to grow they got an
awesome bunch of lovable nerds and we
are stoked to add yet another one to the
ranks we hear i guess that that's the
latin american community that i said i
hope i don't butcher that but latin
american
yeah loud and clear i've never seen that
um acronym oh late below it says
southern europe and latin america so
you're probably in the right realm all
right about representation and we are
honored that immediately through our
bungee bound is now we're excited to add
this new community manager to our ranks
that hails from spain so we got to talk
about bruno so yeah man he's the new
community manager for southern europe
and latin america he basically goes on
to say i know the other world there are
a lot of players to meet a lot of places
to be but oh he's a hunter and us
hunters are known for something it is
for having allies in every corner
complaining
that's what they're known for shut up
trump it always be it ago so i'm ready
for this mission now don't give me that
look travis i might main and arc strider
but i love my three guardian classes
equally i'm always jumping between them
and trying new strats while raiding or
playing trials with friends pvp i like
that i like that using weird but
effective builds is one of my favorite
things to do in the game
can't wait to express all the incredible
things that are coming to destiny 2
along with you both both as an avid
player and as your new community manager
if you're a content creator a veteran
clan leader or new like please feel free
to reach me on twitter so you want to
know what your guardian looks like all
that good stuff the memes so yeah then
he said something in spanish that i'm
gonna butcher nos vemma nos vemos por la
torre gardiani yes something
nos famos like that was koglish
well no vamos is let's go i think uh
wow song lab do you know any of this
travis are you spanish inclined here
i'm not
i took latin sir
because
look at me
you'll know exactly why i i know latin
see you around the tower guardians
that's exactly what it stands for oh
again
guardians
oh he's a pokemon guy too oh nice yeah
hunter idiocy pokemon higher up mancy
okay madrid in the house salute salute
that makes sense for something you don't
like pokemon
you can't bring them around
get people around i salute to him that's
what's up and good to see i mean i got a
couple translations in here thank you
for you guys chipping out by the way
yeah what's the translation what's the
translation well i mean i said it
already see you at the tower guardians
oh okay no um what i was gonna say is i
was gonna ask you guys do you think like
also
destiny's expansion
in these regions like the growth you
know is is really kind of facilitating
this because that is interesting i
didn't know like it was
again i'm guessing that you know maybe
destiny's really popping in these
regions and just internationally and
stuff like that you might know a little
more yeah this feels like a travis
question any thoughts on the broad reach
of bungie now the big baby indy
the baby indeed um i mean what's the
question specifically
just like the the the need for an
additional cause usually
we're so used to like when a new
community manager get announced it's
like we're losing the old one it's like
oh bad boys
here come you know but shout out to dm
you know dmg so it's like now it's like
okay no we're just adding and i'm like
when i first read this
i was like oh no like is are we losing
you know saying like what's going on
dylan like that kind of thing so do you
think it's a result of some type of
expansion internationally that's going
to facilitate the need
yeah it could be um it could it could
also just be that they're still playing
catch up on the fact that they no longer
have a publisher because i know i
remember when they first bought their
independence like i taught i ran into
luke smith at uh
at e3 like right after that happened and
i was like hey what's up luke how you
doing man and we were talking for a
little bit and then he goes
yeah sorry we didn't reach out about the
last thing we did uh we don't have a
pr person i was just like oh wow like
you guys straight up don't have anyone
in any sort of like publishing
uh
position so i think i think they've been
playing catch up a little bit but that
said they're also expanding they're
getting a new campus in the next couple
years that they're building and i'm
pretty sure they're announcing a new
game this year because they they uh they
hired a brand manager for their new
unannounced video game and typically in
my experience i work in marketing you
don't hire a brand manager until you're
ready to actually have the brand out
there in front of people so i think
they're probably going to be announcing
a new game this year and they might be
moving some of their community
management resources over to managing
that game um or you know we don't really
know what it what the layout is going to
look like but my guess would be it's
probably expansion that said if this was
a hire to replace somebody i don't think
they would tell us about the replacement
yet i think you probably
you probably have an incubation period
where you replace your train your own
replacement and that sort of thing so it
might be that somebody is leaving and we
don't know yet but i feel like i hope
it's expansion was it going to say i
feel like isn't there like a german
community manager or something like that
maybe yeah
i feel like i would be i would be
surprised if they didn't have some sort
of international community management uh
arm because
yeah they destiny is a pretty big game
abroad yeah and i know it has like a
different
has like a different store set up in
korea and china and stuff so yeah i mean
you guys you guys have all seen the
different items yeah
yeah those are those are a bit
interesting somebody said maybe current
just all the managers not so much on
spanish and spanish is big for
enough places that that just might be a
reach for be it spanish portuguese
you've got italian french kind of all
that southern european and then latin
america just south of literally where
i'm sitting texas below texas and down
just that whole
area through there you can get a lot
covered so it does seem cool though it
does seem that expansion means something
positive that again bungie seems to be
doing fine to hire and grow and build
new stuff so they are
apparently doing financially okay
well we gotta see i i think uh
tribes are something man i i think like
you said the the whole brand manager
thing and you know we've heard the
rumblings of of matter right and um
it feels about time to start talking
about it right it feels oh for sure yeah
i remember felt like what was it two
years ago what was our man that got
assigned as the head christopher
yes mr barrett so um yeah it feels about
time was that two weeks ago two years
ago you said
it's been a while since he's been
on his own little island yeah
bungie does tend to announce games long
i mean how how many years before
destiny came out did we see that concept
art
that i don't think it was like three i
think it was like three years before
like the the game came out it was pretty
early mm-hmm and what are we speculating
me on matter again i forgot now it's
been so long but what the that is that
like the
i don't know if it's a multiplayer it's
like a multiplayer kind of shooter but
it has like some light elements or
comedic tone
cartoonish maybe like that so it's
it's a competitive multiplayer because
remember we were joking that this is
where they put all of their crucibles
right
right right so why was i thinking so it
has nothing to do with diablo
cooperative type of thing this is more
like a competitive shoot like an event
of like another thing i think it's gonna
be like a hero shooter like overwatch
yeah okay okay got it got it got it it
has a story apparently because there is
a story lead uh somebody got hired to
be like a narrative whatever so it has a
story
[Music]
interesting that's my only that's my
only complaint for overwatch i mean in
fact that nick picked the game was
amazing you know balanced stuff but my
only thing is like you got these crazy
cool characters and it's like there's no
narrative right yeah they feel like i
gotta go outside the game
to learn about the ninja and learn about
like what it did like they look cool
like it'll be interesting to see how
they
play that off and um how that look
let's just can we speculate
i'm in the battle mode if you don't look
at it i rarely get a chance to talk
about it so i'm just like okay
so if we figure in brand manager we
figure in
you know
we how close
to release do you think we are
i think it'll come out in 2024
okay two years okay
yeah i think they if they announce it
this year they might say it's coming out
in 2023 but i i don't think it'll make
it do you think it'd be something where
they give like a tease at summer games
fest as hey this exists and almost 2024
dated to like plant the seed do you
think they would even do that that early
if a brand manager is there
you got six months even before like
summer games fest is that something they
would do that soon
i think i think it could be
middle of this year they have to wait
long enough after which queen is out yes
um yes and i think they i think they
also have to do it
maybe sometime around that they
announced that the next expansion is not
coming out right which i think they will
do inevitably so i could see them doing
it
in between summer and fall
paul seems like it's a little too busy
but they they're gonna i mean how like i
hate to do this because witch queen
isn't out yet but if the expectation is
that they're now doing annual releases
in the spring how much longer until we
hear the name of
or we start hearing like uh what they're
gonna do for um
lightfall yeah right
because i mean that they should be
talking about that this summer if if the
game is really coming out in the spring
which i think there's a zero percent
chance that happens but
uh i'll give them a one percent i'll get
one percent but i can't give them more
than that you're not saying there's a
chance no i don't think there's any real
chance that that comes out next spring
so
i i think i think they announce it this
year if they have a brand manager and i
think that uh
it probably is supposed to come out fall
of 2023 or something and it probably
won't make that window and get delayed
to 2024 would be my guess i have no idea
though if they stick with their spring
cadence
if they're trying to do that again like
when we log in that's what they said
right right i mean that's their goal
that's that somewhere i've seen that
link to me as well i think the same
thing is that
if they are back to an annual cadence
and they're comfortable doing that maybe
the six month or the delay this delay
bought them enough time just kind of
work the buffer out i guess to get
lightfall a little longer time as well
depending on how the teams are working
on everything
if they do that spring and say you go
february march maybe it's like a little
farther
not a full
you know 18 months or something maybe
it's
a 13 month complete year as opposed to
12 months so it might be march it does
feel like they would be planting their
seed if you want to split your games i
guess you don't overlap i'm just about
to ask you that yeah that's what i was
gonna say if there is this other second
like here's the second flag we plant in
the bungee publisher
right you would want that as far from
theoretically your destiny releases as
possible so then you get into your
septembers but they may not they may
want that september time back so you
don't get into your octobers or november
is if call of duty is still a thing if
your starfields are a thing if they're
if that big window is still there for
the holidays if they don't feel quite
comfortable enough they may bring that
thing back a little bit move that flag
to say put their stake back in september
yeah and then if you're at september
march there's your kind of six month
window
so i mean that would be do you think
it'll be destiny related
that's a good question
i mean they've said the destiny world is
gonna live on
i mean if you did a hero for shooter and
a hero shooter for destiny there's
enough characters you could do it easily
yeah and you could make it also like
maybe golden age with all of the or
maybe even like iron lord's age oh now
that where
you know where people you can have those
no you could have like the destiny one
be like all right now you got all the
iron lords coming in and then you have
everybody come
yeah you can just start
on like the destiny expansions from
story into this hero shooter you could
just write the expansions like right now
yeah my only problem with that would be
that they would sort of limit they would
be limited
what powers
classes could do because it's like all
right you're playing as like lord shaq
since it went in in his heyday it's like
all right well he's a titan we sort of
know what powers he has so i could see
that being sort of a limiting factor but
i'm thinking other than that it'd be
kind of cool even though it's not battle
royale what matters gonna be i'm
thinking about how like apex legends is
relation to titanfall's universe yeah
and again they it's not a direct but
it's like within the scope of yeah they
they got some things to play with it's
very interesting to me if they stay in
the destiny unit i didn't even think
about that i was for whatever reason i
was like oh it's just completely
different yeah like the description is
that like lighter comical feel
seems like it would be a bit more
cartoonish and animated seems like it
would be a departure from destiny and
destiny's like is destiny's going to be
the universe that continues
forward after
final shape into something else so that
would be
i don't know if you need to double up on
destiny they could easily do it because
they have the lore and the world and the
characters but i feel if you double up
on destiny then you really become the
destiny studio right right if they're
trying to be a publisher that almost
pidgeon holds them a little too much
into destiny and if they want to bring
in it's kind of going the wrong
direction right and then remember we got
to be honest as much as we are the
hardcore last word destiny podcast
there's there's a group that let's be
honest that won't play destiny right and
maybe they look to get to this kind of
broader audience that wants that kind of
a light whimsical you know comical feel
it's is it i'm very curious to see where
they go i don't know why it intrigues me
so much and um but i'm with you i think
it fits because what i'm thinking is i
look at a season like what we're doing
right now with season of the lost and
that gap
right and you're like bro like that
could literally be
in that place if they were to take the
old activision september to october e
kind of flow and if the new flow for
destiny is that but february march
spring flow
that should seem like enough gap
but um yeah it's it's um it's
interesting i'm very curious about
matter once trav said that brand manager
thing i think he's dead on you do not
hire or announce that unless you're
ready to talk
you got to be ready to talk so at
minimum summer game fest or at the end
of the year the trailer or concept art
of what this thing is going to be
and um i'm excited because this budgie
doing something different on a level so
there's a part of me that is a little
bit excited to see what goes on with it
yeah it's just
sorry for my matter no no i mean it's
been sitting in the background for so
long necromancer by the way with the 20
super chat do you feel that destiny is
struggling with creativity and
imagination like the weapon types they
feel
like modern weapons besides fusion
there's no sci-fi weapons like radiation
plasma rail organic etc style of weapons
i mean that
there's a speculation i would say that a
lot of people are expecting a new damage
type
but again you for a lot of us it feels
like you stick another color on an auto
rifle you stick another collar on a
scout rifle you stick another collar on
an lmg and a rocket launcher and a
fusion rifle and while we are getting
the glaive
that's the problem with their ongoing
universe versus say a destiny 3 as well
is how
you already have all these weapon
archetypes
you can make some slightly different
animations and different sounds and
stuff like lawrence driver sounds really
cool like the sound effects on that one
are really really well done
but on the other side yeah it's
we've talked about this before i wish
solar weapons would eventually set you
on fire the stasis weapons the fact that
agriceptor can freeze you is a tease
again of the idea where some of that
stuff could go but when he talks about
radiation i feel like that gets into the
poison
green damage type we all kind of expect
is going to be
should have been in this expansion
probably going to be in the next
expansion
uh railgun that's almost like linear
fusion rifles and we have arbalest right
now which in a sense is one
organic
i don't even know what that would be per
se
organic yeah i don't know but i mean i i
will say they are
they are kind of at a bit of a capacity
the glaive is something unique because
it's going to be projectile shield and
melee it does three different things
and that's going to be its own type
there's probably only going to be a
couple whether it's one per class and
maybe one other one there's not going to
be a lot of
i don't expect massive
variation between how many different
there's not going to be 20 glaives
i don't expect
now maybe with weapon crafting you can
make it arc solar void who knows
um
but in general i do feel the fact that
we got bows still surprised me and the
fact that they feel good
but again we are getting to a point
where it's like what is a bow i use that
horizon zero done we have hand cannons
we have bacon little pistols
we have
multiple variations of semi-automatic
machine guns
big machine guns little machine guns
semi-automatics single shot all of that
rifle type
and we did get fusion rifles rocket
launchers or something it is that kind
of
grounded a little bit futuristic but not
much a lot of them are still fairly
grounded weapons where do you guys feel
on the creativity because i kind of i do
appreciate the question because i've
wondered how many more auto rifles do i
need and this gets into your vault
cleaning situation as well like how many
auto rifles do you need how many scout
rifles do you need it's it's kind of
just going to be another one
trav
curious
uh
i think
to your point uh e about the different
colors that they need to add
or that that they're considering adding
to the the first slot i kind of think
they have to i think it'd be weird if it
was like unbalanced the way that it is
now where they've just got stasis in one
slot and then the other three are in the
others and also the fact that they added
stasis to that slot
see seems to me like confirmation that
they're going to be adding more in the
future like it just it doesn't seem like
they would have done it so
um i am definitely a fan of them coming
up with more archetypes because i feel
like if the first law and the second
slot are essentially the same thing now
like they're interchangeable just kind
of depends on what
elements you want the best thing they
could do to to break that up a little
bit is to just add more
weapon types and
interesting ideas for stuff and maybe
stop
every time they come up with a new cool
idea for like an archetype of a weapon
they end up just making it an exotic
right and then putting it in an exotic
slot and there's only one copy of it um
and they kind of did that with
the beams right like the the trace
rifles yeah that that for a while was
just an exotic rather than its own
archetype so i feel like if they could
do that more and break off uh the
interesting ideas that they have into
its own little mini archetypes there's a
lot of room to grow in destiny sandbox
and add some new stuff because it does
feel like you know every every time they
announce a new weapon you're like okay
well which of the weapon types is it
going to be and you kind of already know
everything about the weapon before you
use it except for which perks you get
and how that particular weapon feels but
um i i think it'd be cool if they could
they could just add more and get a
little silly with it i'm very excited
for the glaive i think it's gonna be
cool i don't know if it's gonna be it's
not gonna be the meta right like who's
actually gonna use glaives it's probably
just gonna be like a fun thing we use
during the campaign
i don't see it being they're said to
come in hot though so a lot of their new
stuff tends to come in really hot
they aren't they said they're going to
be one of the on
they're going to be the unstopped one of
the unstoppable champion weapons because
i actually just kind of went through
that whole list of other exotics
and i'm guessing they're gonna be what
our fusion rifles are right now like we
have fusions for unstoppables that are
six energy it's a special weapon type
i'm assuming glaives wherever they fall
are going to be
probably 6 energy for the mod because
it's a special weapon type and they're
going to be an unstoppable champion mod
so you use those i'm guessing it's going
to be that
now is it going to be different between
the difference between being told to use
it because that's the meta that they
defined and it actually being good in
its own right because
i i don't think they've ever introduced
an archetype and it's been good right
away um like they did bows right and
bose people used because they were new
but they weren't really like op nobody
was using them as like a meta for
anything right when they came out and i
feel like that that's sort of been their
mo trace rifles too when trace rifles
came out the first they were just a few
exotics but even then people were kind
of just like using them occasionally and
right now when they were made
legendaries they're not really like
blowing up as a class because you can
use them as a legendary weapon now so i
just think it takes them a while to kind
of
figure out
where they are in the meta and i think
the fact that it's melee and ranged
means that it's not going to be great at
either of those things it's probably
going to be middling at both because
it's so
uh
you know it has so much different types
of ways it can be used i just don't see
them speaking i hope i'm wrong it'd be
awesome if graves just kicked ass but uh
then nobody would use swords and
i don't know what would happen in the
meta if yeah
that's why i'm wondering how powerful
because the projectile seemed like a
single shot it's not like you're gonna
be able to shoot frequently the
shielding conceptually seems
interesting but nobody shields
themselves with a sword right now nobody
blocks nobody could care less about that
stat at all like do you have fast charge
soul charge i just swing i don't i don't
block nobody blocks
yeah so i don't know how potent that's
going to be and then you of course got
the little pokey melee
i i don't know i mean again they they
made bows to me something that does feel
good in this game and i got done playing
with a bow for 50 hours and i still
enjoy bows in destiny but again it does
feel weird that it's trying to be a jack
of all trades i worry it will be the
master of none of none yeah
that's kind of my work i'm kind of with
travis i
i don't know if it's going to be the
thing that takes over the slot
it's not going to be
they're going to put it in all the
marketing they're going to make it the
witch queen weapon and again it is an
expansion thing like stasis i
i don't know if it's going to be tied to
the expansion
or if you're or free to player players
are going to be able to get it that
might define how strong it is depending
on how much it costs to get
that price that's that price yeah we got
to see quite quick question random he
would um just talk about weapon types
that what is it the retrace path the
legendary
trace
what's the word on the street how is i i
haven't even shot it i have two of them
and i'm like i don't i want to know
what's the role is is is people talking
about this is something we need to be
using
is it even worth the wait to have this
legendary thing so i'll answer your
question then i'll get to the super chat
in a second yes it's not there's two
super chats um
it's not a bad weapon
when you can get some procs to perk on
it if you can get the right procs it
can't actually do some work uh if you
compare it with harmony you can switch
over and melt pretty well with it frenzy
um
frenzy can put in some work because you
get some good damage if you can get a
good flow of ammo it is potent
like it can do a little bit of work now
versus say a fusion rifle on it's better
at smaller enemies i don't like trying
to dump as much ammo as jobs
yeah it's a trash mob kind of cleaning
weapon that's actually not bad
um i wish it had something like
chromatic fire does to where if you
killed an enemy with it it would get a
little bit of a burst no matter if it's
kinetic or if it's precision or not
because precisions are hard to hit with
that thing but if i'm gonna sit there
and work on like an orange bar night i
feel like i would never use it so i
can't quite not bad for melting i think
for like smaller stuff and kind of
clearing a little bit out with a little
spray
but overall um
i don't know if it's
too good right now the exotics have a
little more to offer so they feel like
they're kind of more worth the slot so
this feels
feels like you have those basic perks on
a weapon that's
needs a smidge more to me i don't know
okay i've heard people like you can have
some fun like if you get a kill and
switch with harmony then all of a sudden
it's you can melt somebody in pvp in
like less than half a second it's it
can't have potential with the right
setup golden tricor tricorn yeah
if you get a kill and then you get a
another kill
with a grenade or a melee ability it
boosted it up to 50 percent more damage
but it sounds more annoying to proc than
even to go for
overall to me i wouldn't worry too much
on it shout out to og k cole by means he
said he got a 50 kill streak with it in
crucible yeah okay so apparently you can
put in some work maybe more of a
crucible weapon than pve maybe yeah that
may be more organic weapons would be
great by the way i just want to point
that out before we leave that super chat
is that if i could have like a a small
mammal a furry creature in my hands that
shot at things and then reloading you're
feeding it this sounds like a
borderlands thing where you've got a gun
shooting batteries with legs or
something yeah
that's where i think you're going but
great matt because what because uh
what's that gun a thousand voices
already kind of looks like it's a living
thing like that some of those eyes on
that thing and have it blank or illegal
or something like that you said eyes and
i just went straight googly eyes i
couldn't not
i mean
eyes of tomorrow with all the eyes
looking all over the place but no right
yeah yeah they could do something like
that but again i don't think that would
change the
arc type it would still be one of the
existing kind of guy and um
insects the the the uh this is true oh
yeah the one that's got a bug in it
the the common air apparently oh no
xenophobia technically has yeah the
amber bug in it yeah mm-hmm uh but dj or
just with the 10 super chat hey guys
long time listener fan of the show yes
we know who you are
you're ridiculous
you're ridiculous
this guy who plays with cog is in his
clan long time listener first time
caller
what is the best game mechanic in
destiny
hmm
game mechanic
uh it does have to be specific to
destiny is my follow-up question it
literally says
you can't be like this mechanic and
horizon is really no in destiny is he is
he sub tweeting me because i don't like
uh ammo synths and
this is really what this is vintage dj
the best mechanic in destiny is
using your super
it's a great mechanic and it wasn't
really being done a lot when destiny
came out with it now it's sort of like
normal to have like a super ability you
like burn into like everybody's like oh
i'm ulting i'm using my oats yeah
that is that is the thing because even
like i noticed sang plants vs zombies
when they came out with a shooter like
now you had the three abilities and
things and your ultimate like plant
ability
no the ultimate ability is more of a
recent addition to game mechanics
the supers kind of i think destiny was
one of the really really early adopters
it was way before overwatch it was like
three three years before overwatch so um
i would say if
you know it was in borderlands uh before
like you had it but i think destiny
really got like that power of popping
off like a really dope super the second
you know you pulled out like a golden
gun or you did like that arc titan
slasher the nova bomb that's probably
like the best one
is true space magic that's yeah yeah
that like ever since those came out i
feel like it's been
just feels good man feels good
i mean
that's a hard for game mechanic is
something that generally
i mean supers have to be up there
it's hard because i mean i'm not going
to go into raid mechanics cause that's
just like boss or enemy design but true
just mechanic of the game yeah i think
the super is kind of going to take it
because i mean right now we've got
how many do we have a lot
nine another great another great
mechanic now or
going to orbit
and joining in orbit i feel like is a
super underrated uh mechanic because
that's like such a part of destiny is
like oh i'm going to orbit like meet me
in space the friendly game that's what i
was going to say
yeah that's like it's kind of just a
cool mechanic like let's just go to
orbit let's go to orbit and like hang
out in space and then we'll like pick a
thing to do because that's like uh in
any other game you're just in a menu and
then it's like all right let's go pick
an activity to do in this menu like
that's how it is in halo halo it's like
all right i'm not
just in a menu and we're waiting for
great destiny
to look at all those eververse ships
that's what that's about
because you look at your mail oh look at
this [ __ ] then you look at the banner
which is a big floss or what how much
dedication and activity yeah it that
that was because i was going to say the
friend game
game and the and the
flex game is all right right there and
then flex games big time yeah you got
some
emblem
ship
emo something if you got something that
you know you can only get from a
specific actor that's why there's more
of those yeah like then you show that
people are like oh wait you got that but
you got that are you like ah that's
right
i recently from a random like eververse
you know the random engrams that you get
i got the pit of heresy sparrow
and i already had the ship a long time
ago which annoyed me and that was just a
reminder of this should have dropped in
the dutch just as when you said it it
just made me want to scream again to say
put more things as in-game rewards
please cool stuff that sets you apart i
mean i was looking through random ships
cause
i don't even know why i was doing it the
whisper of the worm ship
oh i still use that yeah i still use
that
i use the rock now because i got that i
need to get i need to get the rock comet
thing i didn't need to shut the dj i got
they helped me get the uh the three
player player controller evo oh that
one's funny sitting on the camera
yeah the cat's come out with i like that
one yeah cool stuff to make you go in
there and you're like okay
he played you could only get it from
either
time more stuff to seals too for teddy
yeah grinding yeah i mean like outside
of putting a little baby number on your
emblem badge yeah yeah there's by the
way
i have to call out teddy oh what do you
do we were i so as you guys know i
recently completed my dares of eternity
grind which was
i i it was a harrowing journey heroism
oh whoa terrible it was terrible man it
was not good at all
uh
teddy teddy saw i was online and he was
like hey i'll hop into a few with you
and i'm like hey by the way why are you
grinding this are you still
are you still doing
like you still don't have like the the
level 16 or whatever and he does
oh no i'm on my third reset for dares of
eternity
it caps out at five by the way i heard
that yeah i'm on my third reset of dares
of attorney and i was like i'm sorry why
like what i'm out here i'm out here
suffering like like i'm like i'm up on
the cross you know with this dares of
eternity grind and he's like oh no i'm
on my third one and i was like what
explain to me why what is happening and
he was just like oh you know like i got
all the weapons but i don't a few of
them i don't have like the perfect role
so i'm just going to keep doing this
until i go and i was just like
bruh like
what like
like
like why
we need to call an intervention on that
boy it's not even for triumphs dude it's
not even for triumphs it's for you know
he's done with triumphs as soon as they
can be done teddy bear
shout out to travis i mean um shout out
to dj was in there like teddy helped me
with my um
my what you call it catalyst what i was
doing um what is it the dungeon was it
grasshoppers
yeah yeah and it was just like
you're so funny i was so uninvolved in
the last part of the encounter because
they were like he was just like him and
dj was just like two manning the whole
situation they had everything i'm like
jesus like he's a machine bro like it it
is obscene the amount of destiny dollars
he knows and how routine he is with
ritual activities it's since it you know
he's something else he needs another
caddy they got to do something special
for him yeah
uh they did make a kind of mention
basically an update to battle eye
they're still working with it more there
were like 68 players who got banned for
using some process hacker that doesn't
even seem like a cheat it's just like
some
like hardware monitoring tool or
whatever so most of those have been
unbanned but i will i did just want to
bring this up for a quick tag mostly
because
i haven't heard since battle i got
launched this season i have not heard
cheating being rampant not saying it's
non-existent but i will say
it seems like it's been cut down by like
90 or more because i don't hear it
talked about tweeted about clips about
doesn't seem to be as much of a thing
anymore
do you guys kind of get that same
feeling i'm going to defer and try i
haven't i haven't played pc in a while
but uh i i
i mean i do cross play because i play
multiplayer i'm going to ask you players
yeah yeah i i don't see it as much
anymore um
it happens but i yeah i can't really
right like remember times where i was
just like oh my god like get me off
trials this is terrible but then again
i'm i'm also again i'm not playing on pc
really too much anymore and i i don't do
a ton of cross play on xbox so yeah i
don't really know the status there yeah
it's not something
yeah i was gonna say yeah i i mean i
follow a lot of people on bungee twitter
and i don't see the jokes about staying
out of trials it doesn't seem to be
nearly a thing so whatever they did with
battle a
seems to be doing something like i mean
whether it's looking at the algorithmic
you just respawned six times in three
seconds you fired five thousand rockets
in two seconds
those types of things hopefully are a
lot more cotton obvious but
that is swab
but i did want to mention one other
thing actually because dmg put out a
tweet and basically did mention that
there are
some weapons leaving some weapons uh
that will not be staying around quite as
long
and it's a little thread so i'm just
gonna look through and kind of read it
all okay uh seeing some questions about
what weapons will be rotating out of the
nightfall pool
as we've revealed some returning
favorites being added next season here's
a quick list of weapons from nightfalls
trials and iron banner that will be
cycling out so these are the ones that
you want to get
something of if you can't igneous hammer
so that's the trials hand cannon sola
scar that's the solar caster sword
nightfalls you've got the swarm shadow
price the azume sniper which i swear
just got here and hung jury
those are gone wow that did just get
here i feel both like the azumi and the
hung jury are recent it seems like yeah
yeah sure
price are the old ones i feel like those
should be going
iron banner they're good though
multi-modules
everybody's digging on that one lately
time more inspire it's fine guiding
sight and steady hand only one of those
that i really care about would be
multi-mock just because it seems to be a
pretty good one but
but again iron banner's going to get
that rework as well and they also
mentioned from him he's got a couple
here
in an effort to address player feedback
and reduce nightfalls to a three-week
rotation
so you don't have quite as long of a
rotation to get back to the weapons you
want four weapons will be removed on
occasion zur will offer these for
purchase with a random roll
now that we have the legendary weapons
coming through some of these
literal nightfall weapons you could be
able to just click on and buy
yeah definitely
probably not the adapt i guarantee you
it won't be the adaptive normal role
and if if one of those comes through
that's going to be like the xerath of
nails is all the same thing the assuming
is at zero and you can get a god roll by
just clicking on a button
um
now before you hit me with what else is
leaving umbral focusing before season of
the chosen hunt splicer and lost will be
removed highly recommend hunting some
god rolls before what about lead-based
legendary engrams weapons in the
legendary ingram pool will also be
cycling out if you're hunting for a
given weapon turn your gunsmith
materials or dm all your vendor
reputations shacks of all the drifter
before any of the season anything that
you do not redeem will be lost and this
is actually kind of touched on at the
end of the twab bungee rewards season
pass items shacks drifter zavala season
vendor rewards gunsmith reputation
seasonal seals turn in every engram
gunsmith materials all that stuff is
actually going to go away so just
turn everything in no reason to uh hold
on to pretty much anything just you can
check but you don't need to keep
20 engrams sitting at checks you're just
going to lose them you may as well turn
them all in
the gunsmith reputation items i got so
much i have fifteen thousand
like chip at it every time i long and
just chip cause there's so many i have
yeah think about that
but that pretty much wraps up the twab
right here at about a two hour show as
well
um so the swabs that we've got left we
know
void 3.0
weapon crafting on that one
gambit
rework
gambit reworking
it's it's a topic i'll take a week off
that week
yeah
be like uh we have a guest but travis
decided to um
give us a sick note from his doctor so
we will be one man down but that's okay
i was trying to look for the list of
stuff that they've got oh
no that's probably in a previous 12 but
i mean those are the main things what do
you guys think we're going to be getting
next week
can we even i'm just joking
probably
probably gambit i mean they got to get
that out of the way first if they're
trying to build hype they shouldn't be
doing it you know one or two weeks
before that so
last week no it's yeah you're probably
right it's gonna be gambit it's probably
a big focus then weapon craft yeah
weapon crafting's probably the last one
um final piece as well
i keep hearing speculation a lot of
people are thinking stories gonna drop
on tuesday
do you guys think it's finally gonna
drop
i would like it but don't you feel i
hope not
why not
well you talking about in-game game
season is a lost story like will she
come out of the chrysalis
or whatever's going to happen who knows
i have no clue i'm speculating i have no
clue yeah so romans kind of feel like
how do they end the season without
starting the next one i kind of wonder
if they will just wait altogether like
they just won't have really an ending
well apparently there's like a triumph
or something else we've got to finish a
story beat or something maybe something
yeah i think they'll probably do it next
week right that's like two weeks before
the three before three weeks three weeks
yeah it'll be soon if not next week the
week after
at this point i just want to know what's
she going to do
it's gonna be ooga booga bro it's gonna
be ugly
hey guys
isn't crow supposed to be gone so
there's a pretty good chance crow comes
back and and screws something up big
time right yeah i guess that's possible
he could screw with the alignment so
there's a lunar alignment in real life
on tuesday
so that's one speculation if they
actually want to tie it into something
real life related
only other reason
my
i kept hearing that as a thing and then
people are saying hey three weeks before
to give enough people log in and chance
to experience it
but again i think two weeks is still
enough time for you to log in and do
like a 30 minute mission or whatever
it's going to be
i just don't think if they do three
weeks it's going to feel it's it's not
going to be much none of these are the
epilogue's always like
cool
it's i don't yeah he's probably right
it'll probably just be like a a cut
scene and maybe like a small activity
and that's it
i mean we're probably gonna go back
through astral alignment or something
again or the shattered realm one more
time but this time you face a different
i don't know i just
i don't have high expectations for the
epilogue at least right now because they
haven't done much with him yet i don't
expect a live event either which i do
miss
the live event coming in we haven't seen
one of those in a while the big arrival
of savithoon would seem to be fitting
but it doesn't seem like we're gonna get
one
um
but iron banner is the final week so i
think they're gonna do it either one
week before or yeah two weeks before or
three weeks before i just can't decide
which
either way
was that exotic
somebody gonna die
what was that what the spoiler alert
yeah it's called spoiler alert yep
somebody's gonna die
tell you something something happened
man
well i wanna buy the teases we've got
this week seems like akora's gonna be
staying around seems like
uh zavala probably unless he's dying in
that first cut scene fair yeah it seems
like zavala's probably gonna have a
minute it seems like mara saw also
staying around because we got a trailer
talking about that so disappointed wait
wait break it down there's just a little
little 20 second teasers they've done
she just has the yeah one of the
trailers is marasov talking
i missed that when i saw the heiress one
and i was all excited i was like oh
finally i get to see eris well yeah i
think harris will be there but mara's
talking
oh just trust me and it shows like a
video of like the new expansion which
implies that she will be alive during it
so
i know i'm with you man i really wanted
her to i don't want to hurt excited for
her sins
yeah she's a little too arrogant she's
like paracostly though like
yeah she's powerful she is on a that's
kind of she shouldn't die i don't mean
that but i think she's gotta have more
i think she's gotta have something
bigger with savathun before she goes
if she could go down though it would
definitely build up the hype from like
wow sabathan's powerful if she can
actually bring down somebody with her
own throwing world and all that i'm just
saying
as opposed to just snapping her fingers
and taking out spider
ooga booga
yeah we got to see we got to see so next
week is the ruby streets of talking
maybe it seems a lot of people are
thinking next week it does seem to be a
thing i don't know i mean
cross our fingers we've got um next week
we do have next week is going to be a
different time for the show
so next week will be a rare friday
morning show
haven't done one of those in a while but
it will be oh really
travis was like i was like news to me
wait so i have to wake up at 4 00 a.m
whatever your arrival yeah or whatever
your rebels because for me it's eight so
for you it's six
yeah
are we revealing
travis looks so excited you know if you
if you made it this far in the episode i
will reveal so it is a friday morning
episode
9 a.m eastern time we've got marco style
coming on so he was a big division guy
if you guys know him from there but he's
actually covered quite a bit of destiny
um just a really cool content create a
really nice guy but just his time
schedule
um we were able to coordinate and
actually make it work for that friday
morning shout out to cog put in a few
things
um we will be a little quiet on uh some
things but yeah yes
we will
be friday morning 9 00 a.m eastern time
with marco style that will be next
week's guest so
tune in different time i will let you
guys know the promos and the tweets and
stuff that will be in the morning
marco is a friend of yours very cool
well you'll definitely have to be here
yeah i got i got a lot of questions for
you
his his videos have been very
interesting coming from more of an
outsider's perspective yes because it
has been really funny for him to break
down some things or i haven't played
this in a while and oh my god those
moments have cracked me up that he's
done yeah it will be will be a very fun
show kind of see what his expectations
for a lot of stuff and we got to have at
least some spiciness this is actually
our guest canceled this week had to
reschedule on the quietest of all the
twabs
perfect right perfect so we seem to have
had the perfect quiet time with just us
and then we got spice coming in
uh from here to the finish line
oh yeah well as we wrap it up if you
guys want to let him know where to find
you what to look for we will nice nice
and nice and tidy hit that little
two-hour show
i like that talk do it yeah
where can people find you which of the
nine podcasts
[Laughter]
shout out to you this is good that's a
good one shout out to everybody to chat
first of all yeah i was just rapping new
rad i see you doing a promotion i like
that everybody hitting the like button
and coming through shout out to the
people in here yeah shout out to the
boss you'll see more people in here
every time i'm looking and seeing more a
little bit more and more so that's cool
but yeah for me y'all know laura cognito
on twitter online podcast every sunday
is the lord's day if you got a whole
shift at work and you want to waste time
and you're just bored you got a long
drive cross country or a flight i need
to go visit my parent of my wife's
parents in kansas
basically just that show
six hour show for you y'all breaking
news
you could either listen to one episode
of cog show or get your pilot's license
exactly whichever one you want
your learner's permit that you need to
put in behind the wheel you know if you
want 24 people break it down microsoft
activision acquisition
every way possible and every viewpoint
possible check that out also defining
duke man check that out we actually made
two episodes free on our last stand
media the uh one about 10 cent the the
growing you know looming of tencent
check that out and also um drink box
studio so again nobody saves the world
any of you are graham smith check it out
a lot of financial just warning you but
we do talk about the game kind of in a
minute and middle of the end so check
that out and we do have a latest one
that we just recorded with randolph
thorne and chess quartered without
central so xbox two
three
was that a normal defining or was that
ultimate
that's normal when we have a guest okay
yeah you guys definitely have so long
you guys yeah i swear defining duke
since you got there has gotten longer
yeah you come what is what i do
you're like
how long are your podcasts well is
cognito there
because that's a big question
and one last one i do have to promote is
um
sacred symbols for the playstation
people my playstation can't fire people
um we did the collabo with uh sega
symbols and defining duke yeah i gotta
watch that one show that was yeah so
there's a lot of last stand media
content up right now it's been really
cool shout out to maddie man he oh he uh
he told me he was listening to you
slanderers talking about def loop he was
just like you guys this but it's all
good
he had the oh hey
he actually finally played through
chrono trigger so give him a big high
five for me on that one because i know
he finally worked through it recently
um and i was listening to his like
description about hey i really love this
mechanic it started here i love this
thing it started here yeah colonel
trigger is still one of the cool ones
i'm still mad at him because he making
me play some crazy
dang and rapper but
i have to admit it was like squid game
before squid game existed it's not that
good
you really gonna piss them off he said
travis he said i think travis hates me
yeah he told me he's like he was dearly
doing the show he's like i think he's
listening he's like i
no so actually you know what colin
moriarty was the guy who turned me onto
danganronpa and he is huge into that
game or at least he was i don't know if
he's kept up with it but my problem
i have a lot of problems with
i actually have a lot of problems with a
lot of things so it's just enormous
that's true that's true i actually
actually actually don't hate those games
i just think that they're not as
good like if you're going to play a
visual novel where you're trying to
solve murders just play ace attorney
like it's way better that's that's
that's how it started that's how i got
in trouble what you just yeah this is
how this whole thing started real
quickly
i literally i think i was trying to take
five minutes for a reason i don't know i
don't try to take whatever you know this
is a cog six hour podcast guy come on so
at the end of the day
i saw a trailer for the new whatever
attorney i'm like oh that looks cool
oh god i can't believe you said that i
can't believe that's not even in the
same class you need to play the real
game they get robbed like what the hell
is that so i'm like oh i'm never gonna
buy that so i'm good i'm excited
it came in game pass and he was like he
took he literally hijacked the show to
promote this game that now i he knows i
gotta play so i was like
i
you definitely should play it but i'm
just saying that in terms of visual
novels i feel like it it it plays a
little bit too much into the anime
tropes like there's so many like
characters that are just like one
dimensional
burger characters
but i will say it does have a very good
mystery the ending is really cool
solving the puzzles is really cool i
think the second one's better quite
frankly uh the danganronpa two but it's
a literally squid game before squid game
existed in a way
yeah but but here's the thing
assassination classrooms have existed
for way even before danganronpa
danganronpa is copying off of old manga
and so you know you know who you guys
should talk to about this as my
girlfriend she knows everything about
him
she would like to school all of you all
about this i know next time i'm
basically just know nothing about anime
so yeah i'm starting at zero we got a
legend in the chat right now shout outs
about paris lockhart saluted good good
to see you brother xbox's own salute
brother that's got royalty in the chat
yeah i will say this i am glad
danganronpa's on xbox because the xbox
platform has been completely screwed by
atlas and their games for a long time so
it's good to see um that coming out and
i did pick it up i bought it i was like
yup visual novel on xbox a japanese game
gonna buy it you know you gotta support
that happening on xbox okay so here's
another question what was just gonna say
like you've got danganronpa
you've got ace attorney chronicles
i've heard matt talk about shin megami
tensei i don't know where that falls in
any of this stuff
and then you've got like not a visual
novel okay they're cool games and then
that one was interesting i was like he
was about to turn you onto that one and
then you've got like disco elysium which
is not a visual novel but that's more
like you guys talking about like
investigation fantastic
man i hope that comes to getting past
because so many people need to play that
in my opinion ace attorney is like the
best investigator it's definitely the
best visual novel but it's like the best
investigator game because they are so so
good at
like character building and
and oh man i could gush over so you have
a disco
oh um well they're so different yeah for
me for me yeah i would say yes yeah
that's big disco is a great game the
writing and disco elysium is fantastic
but it's not really like uh
it's not really an investigative game in
a traditional sense like a lot of times
you kind of already know what yeah you
know it's just about getting a really
stupid character to figure it out you
know it's like the the goal of that game
but uh if you play phoenix wright like
especially the new ones a lot of people
promote the original trilogy which are
great games but dual destinies and
spirit of justice like if you're those
were the first ones i played and i fell
in love with the series and went back
and played all the old ones because
those games are so well written and by
the end those final cases where you
figure out everything and
and all these twists and stuff it's so
good man it's so good so yeah i play
digging wrong but it's on xbox it's you
know it's it's a good game but i just
don't think it's people try to hold it
up like it's better than phoenix wright
and i'm like it just isn't it just i'm
sorry dude i gotta get you
i just resent him for if death loop was
literally the worst game he played last
year like i want his life like i'm so
upset that that's
i've been doing it all 75 podcasts or
whatever i've been doing 75 or 7 hours
one of the two
what's been up with you man reviewing
and what else is going on with you where
the five yeah i mean i'm i'm grinding it
out man i'm reviewing games i'm doing
previews so i have a ton of content
coming to ign within the next month so
check me out on ign.com follow me on
twitter if you care to at thai guy
travis and then um you know our our
sunday morning show bitcast it's not as
big or as long as the lion lords podcast
uh but we have a pretty good thing going
this past five years we had uh richard
hogue on to talk about the acquisition
we had a really really awesome
discussion about acquisitions and where
this fits in with the consolidation
landscape and what it means for the
industry and that sort of stuff but uh
yeah we had a really good show so you
can you can check that out at um bitcast
or season gaming on youtube just
googling that and uh yeah man i'm just
keeping busy and i'm and i'm preparing
and doing everything in my power to be
ready for which queen i'm my quest log
is empty in destiny i have every
catalyst done i've got all the weapons
and armor that i'd want to get the last
thing i need is i have to complete uh
one more activity
on heroic dares of eternity whenever
that pops up the blight so i got to do
that and then i'm going to get that last
emo and i'll get the seal for uh 30th
anniversary nice and i'll be done i'll
be ready to play
to play destiny uh which queen so i'm
almost done i got to do four runner
catalysts forgot yeah that one's tough
uh i mean you're gonna have to grind to
level 16 to get that if you're not
already so it's a lot that one that that
that almost broke me dude because i was
like i've got every catalyst in the game
and my rule is i don't really care about
seals or triumphs or any of that i care
about stuff that has gameplay impact
yeah and a catalyst for an exotic weapon
like i have to get it i've got to get it
all right let me ask you real quick is
it game changing
how how how much more getting that frag
grenade thing yeah the frag grenade dude
it's pretty good you get a frag like
that's the thing even if it weren't a
game changer cog like do you really not
want to have to have the catalyst
completely like you have to get it and
here's the thing
everybody keeps telling me travis why
are you grinding it it doesn't matter
it's they're keeping dares in no one is
going to be doing dares facts after
which queen drops out you're right
you're right now or do all the new stuff
that's basically it you're going to be
playing with those level 1 blueberries
or what is it going to be level 1350 now
yeah i don't think that there's going to
be any blueberries playing it because
yeah i just i i think that activity is
going to be so level 16 or whatever it's
an auto drop
yeah you get it automatically and i just
got to work it did it just kills to
complete the catalyst yeah what you have
to do is you have to just keep doing uh
the event the activity until you're
level 16. when you're level 16 you get
an item and the item makes you run one
last stairs of eternity and get a score
of 22 500 and in order to do that you've
gotta run a heroic version there's one
way to get your hideout score so you run
one heroic and then you get the
catalysts on that and these kills yeah
just kidding all right
he got a video i'll be watching
i actually don't have it yet so that's
covered too
i'm done with all of my destiny homework
and now i'm just going to be working on
reviews and previews until the game
comes out so i'm in a pretty great
position for destiny i'm feeling good
about it and i've got like three weeks
of not playing the game where i'm not
going to win myself out and stuff so
i'm feeling pretty good yeah e
uh for me
finished horizon finished my home
projects for a little while nice yeah
dude sounds like you've been a handyman
lately oh yeah literally just taking
apart a garbage disposal and putting a
new one in and then i had the new i've
installed all the three toilets on our
house are all installed by me so i've
literally gotten a bit efficient at this
but this one do you do house calls
you're a bit far away sir
you're gonna have to cover the travel
expenses and uh the travel time plus
mileage so we will discuss
[Laughter]
moving on no like i think i got that
stuff out of the way so i'm working on
uh nobody saves the world kind of
offline maybe and then as elden ring
is right around witch queen i was
debating on dark souls one remastered
because it's one of those kind of major
souls games that i have missed so that's
one that i was thinking stream would be
entertaining oh my god
quick story at the end i told these two
as well
i literally got the mail today
and i got a jury summons
for february 23rd
at 8 am amazing now i've already gone
online and asked for a deferment for
like
about nine weeks so i can be in the week
nine of the season i figure week nine on
a wednesday can't be that crazy but i
see that and i'm like it cannot be that
day
i opened it my draw jaw just hit the
floor i could not believe that was the
day
you couldn't do it three days before
that yeah they trying to mess with you
bro yeah for real somebody even my
discord is like man savathun's at
getting in real life now trying to get
you summoned out of here
i was i was not thrilled but uh yeah
whether you guys find me on twitter
posting
who knows what i'm i now play wordle
every morning so yep i'm addicted to
that too
um i just got done cooking a homemade
chicken pot pie i still gotta work on
making my own pie crust but the chicken
pot pie
it was a recipe from our neighbors
actually we every blue moon trade meals
with them
it's a chicken pod you ever feel like
ibontus's life is way fuller than ours
yeah
we talk oh all we talk about is just the
podcasts were on that's it or like the
games were like i built two houses yeah
he's like i built this house
i'm crazy i'm raising my family i've got
a dog and a wife and we're just like wow
i've got a void in my life like i don't
have any of this going on i wasn't like
you know
like what does that look like the mayor
yeah
it's funny because yeah he's got so much
going on like in real life i'm like my
regular life is whack really well here
how about icing on the cake yesterday we
were figuring out enzo has to get acl
surgery just like raya went through
oh wow he's been limping for a little
while and he sometimes he gets so like
amped up and bouncy but he would
actually put weight on the back leg
but then other times he'd be like
limping and almost holding it in the air
so we finally got him looked at because
we just got done getting through our
positions are your dogs playing football
are they getting their earbuds no you
have air bud dogs no
it's just something that can happen
to dogs
so
we've got that yeah so
yeah apparently there's stuff going on
but you guys know i like to cook that's
not news yes yeah that's chef i know
without the condiments just but it but i
guess what i was going to say about the
chicken pot water before we go
you know how you do yeah i know
okay anyway the flavor i just like this
chicken pot i don't normally like
chicken pot pie because it's like the
cream base generally this is just the
chicken broth no but it's like i like
the chicken pot pie because of the
chicken like stock but it's just very
reduced
but you don't actually some
[Laughter]
finish
episode number 182
january 27th this is
this is ty guy travis over there this is
an incognito and it has been
forgive
us the last word